tous les plus grands tournois d'échec il
se déroulent en présentiel ou en ligne
vivez comprenez en direct les parties
des meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec
les commentaires en français de nos
experts notre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
bases retrouvez toutes les infos
essentiels comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les comptes-rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour
ce cette direct du tata style chess
India rapide et Blitz évidemment
nous aurons Maxime va chier la grave à
suivre le numéro 1 français pendant
tellement longtemps
champion du monde de Blitz 2021 et ça
tombe bien parce que c'est du rapide et
du Blitz j'espère que vous allez bien ça
commence à 11h30 bonjour tout le monde
où vous soyez d'ailleurs sur twitch que
je vais suivre en priorité je pense quoi
que j'ai les messages YouTube aussi donc
Youtube de cheesecom on doit être aussi
en direct sur chaise 24
en français bref on est partout vous
pouvez pas rater donc ravi évidemment de
vous retrouver début des parties
normalement à 11h30 je vais vous montrer
que j'ai bossé pour une fois et on voit
Maxime va chez la grave alors là c'est
coup de bol parce que j'ai cinq caméras
donc une parachutier et énorme coup de
bol j'avais programmé une caméra au
hasard et ça tombe sur Maxime ça
commence bien et on verra que Maxime
joue pour cette première partie contre
est-ce qu'on a les 10 joueurs oh là là
c'est c'est juste c'est trop là
c'est trop Maxime va chez Lagrave donc
en numéro 1 il a dû tirer le 1 ou pas
parce qu'il a les Noirs à la première
donc il a pas dû tirer le 1 mais en tout
cas même maximum tête peut-être c'est le
hello rapide qui joue en ordi bec à dos
santorov ouais alors lui il est très
très fort évidemment le jeune ouzbek
mais d'ailleurs olympique avec
l'Ouzbékistan donc médaille d'or et
aussi champion du monde de partir rapide
en 2021 je crois que c'est l'année du
sacre de de Maxime il avait gagné le
rapide et Maxime le Blitz Alexander
grichu que l'on ne présente plus le
peut-être le dernier
un des derniers survivants de la
génération des 40 nerfs qui jouent
encore à ce niveau là donc grosse
expérience great je suis connue pour ses
notes
voilà donc là ça tombe bien c'est dur
rapide et Blitz donc en général il est
très très fort il était champion du
monde de Blitz plein de fois ah mais je
Babou progenda alors
magnifique finaliste de la dernière
Coupe du monde face à
face à Magnus Carsen en éliminant au
passage
icaru Nakamura et Fabiano caroña autant
vous dire que c'est la croix et la
bannière pour avoir participé un bon
nombre de fois à cette à cette Coupe du
Monde c'est chaud d'arriver en finale
donc voilà une des premières
participations et tout de suite la
finale donc un client très sérieux
ensuite on a visite qui est un des
meilleurs joueurs indiens depuis très
très longtemps
enfin très très longtemps il a 27 28 ans
donc c'est pas non plus
ça fait pas non plus des dizaines
d'années ensuite on va te mouradjabo
évidemment très connu aussi numéro 1 à
zerry très très fort joueur et
spécialement rapide et Blitz et ensuite
des Indiens donc art June et reggaizy
je n'ai regga easy qui est qui a fini
quart de finaliste qui a perdu contre à
la dernière Coupe du monde donc
très très fort joueur aussi gouquet
évidemment qui a si vous avez pas suivi
il a pris la place de numéro 1 indien à
la première fois depuis 37 ans ou 36
enfin quelque chose comme ça donc voilà
assez impressionnant Google
pentes à la récré China alors là c'est
peut-être c'est l'ancienne génération
alors un Kristin je conduis je sais pas
si je le dis je continue en 1998 pour la
première fois donc je connais très très
bien
très fort joint indien peut-être la
génération d'après d'après un ordre qui
a toujours plus de 2700 évidemment on a
des joueurs qui ont tous plus de 2700 et
le dernier c'est le jeune joueur
allemand le numéro allemand Vincent
gamer
très fort joueur aussi et oui comme on
me le fait remarquer ah juste titre dans
le chat
cinq joueurs indiens bah écoutez c'est
bien normal on n'est jamais mieux servi
que par soi-même et donc ils invitent
plein de joie à dire on a Gretch ou
camvel dans cette première ronde visite
à Krishna Google
mais évidemment évidemment celui qu'on
va suivre ce sera Maxime va chez Lagrave
tant que les autres parties
tant que cette partie là n'est pas
terminée évidemment qu'on suit qu'on
suit Maxime en priorité et même j'ai
envie de dire en tout cas pour l'instant
en exclusivité vous avez comme
d'habitude à droite les chéquiers et le
Grand Échiquier où je vais bouger les
pièces je vais vous faire des flèches
comme ça ouais il joue pas il joue pas
il joue pas 4 il joue des 4
donc on est allégé
décalage et on a le live board de
l'autre côté
et par contre je vois pas le truc update
alors là je vois pas les coups alors
comment je les coupe
alors
j'ai les coups sur mon échiquier
il y a un truc
ouh là là j'ai pas changé et vous voyez
la confiance mais vous inquiétez pas ça
va revenir
dans
je sais exactement le problème et voilà
on a les coûts de ce système de Londres
donc le système de l'endé 4K F3
typiquement on met le foin F4 ici c'est
ce qui fait avec saveur get shook a
priori
Maxime ne voulait pas ça c'est sûr jouer
sa greenfeld habituel mais son gamin
accepté sa deuxième ouverture donc c'est
4 puis on prend ces quatre et le 3 et on
va reprendre et voilà bon c'est une
telle ligne principale sur des quatre fu
F4 c'est 5 E3 qui est C6 jouer par mvl
assez rapidement ici le coût consacré
c'est kbd2 mais grichu qui avait déjà
joué fou et deux ici
donc intéressant
est-ce que ce tournoi compte pour la
qualification candidat dans une certaine
manière
non principalement non ça compte pas
mais attention il y a le tour fidèle
qu'est-ce que le tour filet donc c'est
le tour de la Fédération internationale
des échecs où on marque des points en
fonction des tournois et donc c'est sûr
que ce tournoi vu son niveau rentre en
considération dans ce calcul final et
donc c'est clair que
c'est clair que ça compte finalement
donc alors attendez je vais aussi pour
couser le liveboard parce que j'avais
commencé à faire ça le liveboard ah ben
voilà ça marche tout marche bien ah non
ça va être bon je vais faire ça voilà et
donc vous avez à ma gauche le liveboard
avec le en temps réel si vous voulez
réfléchir à votre vitesse et à droite
donc là où je fais mes flèches
et je m'amuse pour essayer de vous
expliquer à quoi y réfléchit des trucs
là il réfléchit à pas grand chose il
connaît évidemment cette position il est
juste en train de choisir en train de
voilà de
prends un petit peu la température bon
de ces gritchouc là il procrastine un
peu voilà deux minutes passées ici ça
sert à rien mais bon c'est du 25 + 10
donc ça reste raisonnable on a toujours
ses 10 secondes
de rajout qui sont très intéressants je
rappelle le format du tournoi le format
du tournoi c'est 3 jours de partir
rapide avec trois rangs de par jour tout
simplement on joue tous les adversaires
donc il y a 9 rondes et ensuite deux
jours de Blitz effrénées ou on joue 9
randes contre un neufrandes contre les
joueurs et après couleur inversé on
rejoue le lendemain donc je suis avec
vous pendant ces cinq jours incroyables
et oui
donc ça va ça fait plaisir on va voir si
Maxime qui nous habitué quand même a
beaucoup de
de belles choses notamment en rapide et
Blitz
évidemment mais quand même sans presse
son titre le plus important c'est
évidemment champion du monde de Blitz en
2021 donc c'est quand même ça spécialité
et on espère le voir briller c'est le
même format que le grand chest tour et
et voilà dans le grand chasso il a fini
troisième l'année dernière du de la
globalité il a déjà gagné un grand chez
soi à Paris bon bref grosse gros
palmarès mvl évidemment c'est quoi la
cadence Beach je pense que c'est du 3 +
2 ou 5 + 3 peut-être 5 + 3 Comment
grandes tours là c'est bonne colle
Thibault 179 donc en fait je lis les
deux chats j'ai deux chats qui arrivent
sur mon
sur mon écran donc YouTube un peu
mélangé d'ailleurs c'est un peu bizarre
mais je vois d'où ça vient de Youtube et
de twitch donc n'hésitez pas à nous
rejoindre sur Youtube et twitch si vous
voulez chatter évidemment pour ne rien
rater si vous êtes un peu
[Musique]
étourdi ou pas d'ailleurs mais si vous
avez besoin d'un reminder à pour tous
les jours à
à 11h30 et même pour les prochains parce
qu'en ce moment on a du speech aussi
c'est le format cheesecom speechers
qu'on a vu quand on a qu'à moi hier ne
faire qu'une bouchée du joueur chinois
yangi voilà speechesse avec tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde à Maxime
Nakamura pas en 3 semaines donc
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner aux chaînes
et comme ça vous ne ratez rien du tout
de tout ce qui se passe en ce moment et
il s'en passe des belles choses
sur chaise.com
s'il est point à l'eau salut j'ai pas
compris ils prennent des points ou pas
alors vous savez pas les parties
classiques oui un classement rapide et
Blitz qui est en jeu évidemment c'est
moins c'est encore moins important que
le classement de parties classiques mais
quand même ça joue un petit peu
ah est-ce qu'on suivra les parties du
côté noir mais oui où ai-je la tête
ouais je la tête est-ce que je vais
réussir à faire ça
ah non
comment fait-on pour tourner les
chéquiers
extraordinaire
extraordinaire ça va être là
regardez-moi regardez-moi ça évidemment
qu'on suit ça du côté noir toutes mes
excuses et je vais mettre l'autre aussi
du côté noir et oui oui bien sûr et oui
bien sûr qu'on fait ça
et oui bien sûr bien sûr qu'on suit
Maxime va chez Lagrave
du bon côté
voilà donc x 2 donc je vous parlais ce
petit coup de
non alors c'est la mauvaise fenêtre pour
moi
hop là ce petit coup de donc je vous
parlais qui a été c'est la signature
gritchouk mais il y a quelques années
déjà je regardais je regardais ça vous
pouvez donc on sort les fous avant les
cavaliers ce qui n'est généralement pas
conseillé
mais bon c'est pour c'est pour des vies
un petit peu normalement le cavalier
vient ici alors évidemment le problème
ça pourrait dame B6 attaque B2 attaque
des 4 mais je suppose que le coup ça
serait qu'il y ait ces trois ici
attention menace et B5 menace cavalier
A4 donc on se garde un peu plus de
flexibilité avec ce cavalier ce qui est
pas forcément une mauvaise idée dans ces
systèmes de Londres parce que c'est vrai
que le fou normalement il va pas il va
pas faire grand mal au noir et donc faut
deux un coup intéressant
qui a mis quand même 4 minutes à jouer
bon il a
il était il était clairement
en train de choisir je sais pas ce qu'il
fait bon
c'est juste cette discussion une fois
avec quelque chose j'ai dit écoute Sacha
que j'aurais pu très longtemps
je sais pas enfin la même génération
je dis bon maintenant il faut jouer plus
vite il faut arrêter avec ses amis il me
dit c'est comme si tu demandais à l'écho
de ne plus avoir peur
c'est dans les gènes il est exactement
utilisé cette expression là voilà je
peux rien faire
bon sur ce sur ce genre de discours
c'est typique de l'humour de greachuk
qui est
quelqu'un de très de très sympathique
avec beaucoup de
[Musique]
beaucoup d'humour beaucoup de
sarcasmes voilà
donc clairement
[Musique]
et ah il est bon ouais il est bon alors
pas de regret pour ton parcours de
champion du monde vu le ticket accordé
un jour écoute
qu'est-ce que je te dis je te dise moi
la Coupe du monde j'ai joué le
demi-finaliste hein Amazon au deuxième
tour j'ai pas vu venir très en forme il
y a très bien joué il a pas fait une
soirée dans notre match il a fait un
très gros match je peux pas dire que
j'ai mal joué de partie nul en partie
classique et ensuite
en rapide j'ai senti que un moment fait
que je saisise ma chance je me suis pris
les pieds dans le tapis et j'ai perdu
donc il a été il a été il était très bon
Amazon
puis derrière il a fait un tournoi
demi-finaliste donc probablement tu
auras des candidats donc mauvais tirage
effectivement de petits pôles à 2630
Amazon
c'était pas le meilleur 2630 à jouer
hein vu sa performance du tournoi il a
fait le tour de sa vie et ça a commencé
par là j'étais un peu au début de ça bon
c'est comme ça car l'adversaire joue
très bien
je sais pas si mal joué en plus je peux
pas trop m'en vouloir honnêtement
de ce de ce match parce que je peux pas
faire beaucoup mieux en fait quand un
adversaire fait pas d'erreur c'est
compliqué
alors
on voit tout le monde
aussi oui beaucoup de déception pour moi
dans ces donc j'ai joué beaucoup j'ai
champion de France Coupe du monde et
notamment il a division 2 aussi en
berkup et effectivement des toits qui
sont pas très bien passé
il y a pas là 1080p sur le stream si si
si si à jour d'Alpha pourquoi ça marche
mal dites-moi si quelque chose va pas
c'est le premier jour donc on sait pas
donc
voici mais j'irai aussi il m'a fait une
deuxième partie m'a fait une deuxième
partie parfaite donc c'est dur
enfin encore plus parfaite lui que que
c'est dur qu'on des joueurs qui jouent
aussi bien c'est dur de s'en sortir
c'est comme ça quelques erreurs et c'est
terminé
d'accord merci
quelles sont les prochains tours
auxquels je vais participer
chaque XBL pas grand chose
pas grand chose j'ai un grand tournoi
peut-être mais c'est pas moi de
l'annoncer à quel tournage je vais
participer mais j'ai une bonne nouvelle
récemment donc je laisse je laisse la
personne
[Musique]
la personne en charge
de la sélection
je balance la je crois
deux de le dire voilà
de d'annoncer d'annoncer sa sélection
mais peut-être que peut-être que
peut-être que j'aurai une bonne nouvelle
sûrement
alors
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe faut 2 puis
on prend puis on prend fou G4 et C3
c'est normal de prendre des 4 toutes les
réaction tout à fait logique on amène à
une structure cars balles qu'est-ce que
ça se battre pardon on avait pu lancer
trois D4 contre e6d5 et donc voilà bon
ben une structure très très connue
évidemment très confortable pour les
Noirs parce que le Fou est en dehors de
sa propre structure de pions donc tout
va bien pour les Noirs mais tout va bien
pour les blancs ça reste une position
jouable c'est pas mal pour pour Maxime
c'est pas mal pour greatue
bref tout le monde tout le monde est
bien tout le monde est content
voilà pour le format coupe moi je viens
donner mon avis mais on fera ça on fera
ça au pause
on fera ça aux poses de ces tournois
coupe pas coupe moi vous le savez je
suis plutôt un adepte du
spectacle je
place du point de vue du public voilà il
me semble
m'exprimer au nom du public et mais
vu les retours que j'ai en tout cas il
me semble
que le format coupe est quand même plus
agréable à suivre et plus excitant à
suivre
si on en croit aussi peut-être je sais
pas toi qui marche comme Roland-Garros
ou c'est format coupe ou la ou la coupe
du monde de foot voilà ce genre de chose
ou c'est format quand même
c'est format coupe qui sont quand même
très très suivis
alors j'ai essayé de chercher ça Yark
est-ce que quelqu'un peut trouver ou
alors le tournoi est en Inde mais je
sais pas ah depuis que le kata ah bah
oui magnifique c'est marqué c'est marqué
depuis quand le kata voilà donc on était
à la China l'année dernière et l'Inde
qui devient vraiment grâce à grâce à
Vichy à Nantes qui est une légende
vivante là-bas clairement une sorte de
Zidane Zidane indien grâce à lui et bien
[Musique]
et bien oui tout à fait quelques temps
en français et donc
[Musique]
ouais donc voilà grâce à Vichy à Nantes
clairement sous son impulsion il y a eu
beaucoup de
beaucoup de nouveaux tournois C3 E6 et
voilà tout est normal alors est-ce qu'on
développe le cavalier là est-ce qu'on
fait dame B3 on essaie de chatouiller
par là en B7 parce que si on fait rien
si on se développe normalement on peut
dire qu'on va faire des 6 on aura
vraiment aucun problème avec les noirs
les gens pas quand même c'est vrai
ouais j'ai voulu dire que même si pour
le public c'est plus sympa bon ben
écoute on en discutera que dit love
oppose
mais ouais
on verra tu sais se faire éliminer du
premier tour de Roland-Garros c'est pas
très agréable non plus c'est un sport ça
s'appelle comme ça chaque fois j'en
reparle en plus je dis que j'en parlais
plus tard mais j'en repars on a on a
cinq jours pour en parler avec plein de
poses
et c'est intéressant d'ailleurs pourquoi
on ferait pas un sondage
voilà on pourrait le faire dans le chat
même tu sais faire ça Nathan il est là
qui sait faire ça on fera ça on va faire
un sondage cheesecom là
twitch chez com qu'est-ce que vous
préférez vous à une formule à
élimination directe ou une formule ou
une formule toute ronde qu'est-ce que
préfère le public parce que au final
c'est quand même le plus qui regarde
s'il y a pas de public il y a pas de
sponsor voilà les joueurs ils sont
marrant sûrement les joueurs s'ils sont
éliminés d'entrée il y a pas de tournoi
ils peuvent pas être éliminés d'entrée
ça c'est vrai
on peut faire les trois les trois
options
et à toute ronde non on peut pas faire
des sur twitch si quelqu'un sait faire
de lancer un sondage
avec trois options un format knockout un
format
poule plus après tantout ou un truc tout
rond
ouais ça serait intéressant moi ça
m'intéresse vraiment de savoir
alors
quelle idée de foudre par Maxime Achères
il faut prendre ici et petit rock
écoutez ce que je vous avais dit
exactement tout va bien ici pour les
pour les pour les noirs et pour les
blancs aussi mais les blancs pas obtenu
davantage d'ouverture ça c'est
complètement évident
donc petit rock va certainement être
joué quoi d'autre on peut pas trop
s'enflammer là je crois pas Maxime aussi
qui prend son temps d'habitude il met
une pression dingue
ah le liveboard faut aussi le mettre en
ouais tu as raison tu as raison tu as
raison
alors moi je vais mettre là le liveboard
on va voir comment il va faire pour
soldat
on va garder un œil sur ce liveboard
mais voilà petit rock va être joué très
certainement par Maxime qui réfléchit à
quoi Maxime est-ce qu'il veut faire
cavaler le 4 d'abord
je n'ai pas la relève de Maxime
je n'ai pas la ref quand une partie on a
trois parties aujourd'hui the mighty
gogoudou
trois parties tous les jours de rapide
petit rock petit rock voilà normal
qu'est-ce qui va jouer quelque chose
ce que je peux faire un défilement
automatique tout un jouet
par Alexander gretchup tout à fait
normal on prépare la sortie du cavalier
en le 5 ça va être l'enjeu pour les
noirs
d'empêcher ça
et
[Musique]
on va voir avec les Noirs peut-être
qu'il est 17 ici pour empêcher ce
cavalier de 5 contrôler cette case de 5
avec le petit piège si on joue à 6 on va
le montrer ce petit piège qui est assez
connu on peut pas prendre ici sinon puis
on prend on perd une pièce
si dames prend il faut ranger 4 et
attention la tour à taclades donc il y a
pas de moyens vraiment de s'en sortir on
est obligé de prendre E2 ça me prend le
2 et c'est vrai que les Blancs alors
sans avoir un avantage
gagnant et quand même bon
quand même un petit peu mieux on a
obtenu un petit truc
tout droit évidemment il va pas faire F6
Maxime on peut aussi prendre parfois
garder les cavaliers dans ces positions
fermées c'est intéressant on peut
préparer l'attaque de minorité mais bon
ça je suis pas sûr
en général on joue surtout avec les
noirs pour essayer d'empêcher les idées
blanches et 16,50 2 minutes de moins
pour Maxime
aucun souci
mais les deux joueurs qui jouent quand
même à leur rythme bon j'espère que à
son âge en cours merci
bravo vous pouvez voter
coupe moi je vote coupe
il faut que je m'inscrive je suis pas
connecté ouais mais j'ai pas le droit de
vote allez
j'ai pas le droit de vote
mince alors je vote pas
on va voir allez-y n'hésitez pas à voter
sur le sondage quel format de toi
préférez-vous tout simplement
voilà on fait
on fait ça à suivre vous êtes des
spectateurs ouais je prépare un cours
sur chessable Gunther Love mais alors je
suis en retard mais alors on essaie
honteux même moi géante et il en faut
beaucoup pour géante et là je t'assure
que c'est un vrai désastre
on voit allez-y voter
n'hésitez pas c'est beau le vote on vote
on fait les gens on fait voter les gens
et après on fait ce qu'on veut c'est ça
le démocratie
ouais alors oui mais tu tends alors H6
cavalier 5 on va regarder dame prend
c'est vrai qu'on peut essayer de s'en
débarrasser mais je vais en remettre
soit je vais revenir là et la casse des
trois elle est belle parce que je vais
contre les cases soit j'en mets une
couche par là mais c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait changer effectivement il y
aurait pas grand chose donc il est 7 sur
un bon coup ici si on avait pas le choix
on ferait ça et ce sera toujours à peu
près équilibré quoi que les Noirs les
Blancs jouaient pour l'enquête des trois
ensuite KF3 ce qui a vraiment quelque
chose je pense pas
ça sort pour quand il est le retard mais
si je le savais moi
j'en sais rien je suis désolé mais là je
suis tellement
c'est dur
c'est dire je suis désolé je suis désolé
Google il sera bien non il va être on va
travailler dessus
alors tour à 8
jouer par Maxime ma chérie ok il veut
clairement mettre une tour ici alors je
comprends son idée son idée ça va être
de faire ça et sur cahier des 7 cahier
des trois on va préparer la poussée de 5
peut-être F6 d'abord et E5 c'est très
thématique pour avoir cette phalange de
pions sans trop très intéressant ce que
fait Maxime un coup profilactique tu
auras 8 dirigé contre cavalier E5
intéressant
est-ce que comme quality chaise tu peux
dire année 2024 sur la date de sortie
chez scum fr
j'espère franchement
2023 je crois que c'est mort
soyons réaliste 2024
[Musique]
j'espère
mais bon salut French Fighter 2007
alors tour à 8
jouer par Maxime qui va se réfléchir si
vous avez parti marrantes à regarder si
vous voyez d'autres parties à côté parce
que j'ai pas accès à toutes les parties
n'hésitez pas à me dire mais je pense
qu'on reste sur Maxime quand même
évidemment
en tout cas tant qu'il est en contention
pour la première place
sur un autre truc en retard à rattraper
je suis pareil je compatis ouais ouais
moi je suis bon de sur les deadlines
c'est aussi un truc à faire pour rendre
pour le lendemain je suis très bon voilà
par exemple il y a un show vous voyez un
chaud à gérer pour le lendemain la
veille et la veille et le matin je suis
en oui je suis en ébullition
je suis là je me suis à fond voilà mais
là c'est un projet trop long là j'arrive
pas là
pourquoi il te chaises bravo c'est nous
une chaise ou cheesecom de la grande
famille en fait chez com Nathan
c'est new inchestre
donc du coup ça fait que la grande
famille
très bon bouquin aussi très bon bouquin
si on a une chaise
ouais
mais là c'est juste une de ma faute je
sais pas si ils sont très très pro en
général
même en
particulier et ils sont très très
proches et Balin donc là c'est vraiment
c'est vrai en moi je suis seul et unique
responsable il y a pas de je sais pas me
cacher derrière mon petit doigt
le prochain de ma prochaine publication
c'est pas ma prochaine c'est la c'est la
seule et unique pour chasser voilà après
j'arrête ce sera la lifetime répertoire
sur la sicilienne chouchnikov
ça sera bien je vous le dis alors quel
format préféré vous prend une photo
alors on va faire une photo
une photo alors format préféré vous
on a
le c'est terminé
58% pour le plus couple
31% coupe knockout toute ronde 11%
bon voilà
ça a duré longtemps
va pas revenir pour le contenu vidéo
limité va non ça va pas revenir la seule
question à laquelle j'ai pas la réponse
c'est est-ce que les vidéos de chaise 24
vont être transvasées sur le site chez
com ça je sais pas on m'a posé cette
excellente question notamment à l'Alpe
d'Huez d'un abonné premium que je
remercie s'il nous écoute voilà qui
s'inquiétait de ça et il avait bien
raison de s'inquiéter de ça les blancs
passent un C4 un jour non non il y a le
pion des 4 qui est faible on ne fait
jamais ces cas dans ces structures à
plutôt essayer de gagner de l'espace
avec la 4 à 5 ce genre de choses sachez
avec ses 14 minutes contre 15 tout va
bien
merci pour le sondage alors est-ce qu'on
fait un autre sondage moi je propose un
autre sondage je vais voter les gens
est-ce que est-ce que vous voulez
regarder tout le temps sur la partie de
Maxime ou alors est-ce que vous voulez
que je j'aille à droite à gauche et que
je revienne sur la partie de Maxime la
plupart du temps mais quand on aille
voir quand même un petit peu les autres
parties ou alors on fait 100 % la partie
Maxime sachant que pour les Blitz la
question se pose même pas en suivant
l'intégrité mais pour les rapides c'est
qu'on a un peu de temps et qu'on peut
changer
si quelqu'un peut créer son archet bien
moi je fais des sondages je les sondage
tout le temps mais je sais pas les faire
sur sur twitch si quelqu'un peut le
faire Maxime tout le temps ou toutes les
parties attends tu vas pouvoir voter
c'est pas un montant on va faire un vote
votre twitch c'est très bien ces trucs
là
je sais qu'il y a tellement de fans de
Maxi mais un qui espèrent une remontée
évidemment lui je souhaite de rejouer
les candidats pourquoi pas un shot au
titre mondial un de ces quatre
alors qui suit ton sondage en cours
n'hésitez pas à voter qui suit ton un
100% mvl à multiplex ou là c'est serré
c'est très serré
c'est très serré n'hésitez pas n'hésitez
pas merci
les vidéos Seri ouais les vidéos séries
qui étaient qui étaient quand même bien
faites
alors Alexander greachuk
i n'hésitez pas à voter oh là là c'est
du 48 52 là 47 53 c'est vachement plus
serré
Sacha qui réfléchit moi petit coup de la
4 ça fait pas de mal mais bon
faut qu'ils dépêche il a raté son
ouverture clairement
multiplex mvl 55 ans
est-ce qu'elle est partie intéressante
c'est ça à côté
c'est ça je vais rester
si je vois des parties intéressantes à
côté
alors ça c'est quand même
c'est le combat des chefs aussi mais bon
la partie est pas
extraordinaire Éric et une partie
intéressante
Raja bof Prague
ouais
clairement donc c'est intéressant quoi
qu'il arrive
exactement qui dit love le système
perdure pour les anciens c'est à dire
que si vous avez été premium sur chaise
effectivement vous gardez vos avantages
et les vidéos séries restent et à 4
jouer pas Alexander grichu comme annoncé
on veut prendre un peu d'espace
peut-être à 5 peut-être dans ma 4
peut-être même un pion à 6 c'est très
très 2020 tout ça
bon pour l'instant en tout cas sur cette
partie on va rester sur mvl la ML qui
prend léger ascendant au niveau du
sondage 100% FVL voilà on aura on aura
les autres peut-être qu'il y aura il y
aura d'autres parties s'il y a une
partie vraiment très spectaculaire
effectivement pour aller la voir
n'hésitez pas à me dire mais je crois
qu'on va on va quand même rester sur
Maxime c'est partir rapide dans le temps
de bien s'imprégner de la position bon
là effectivement on a gretchou qui est
quand même très très lent donc
effectivement ça peut vous paraître un
peu un peu au ralenti mais c'est quand
même
ça va s'accélérer vous inquiétez pas
l'échapper tu me dis aussi Nathan
n'hésite pas à me dire parce que tu
préfères
aussi
il y aura un gros zinote au moins tout à
fait et c'est pas le moment on va partir
donc à 4 était le coup complètement
normal que j'avais proposé à tempo c'est
un coup qui rejoint c'est ça qu'il faut
voir aussi
il a mis combien de temps à jouer à 4 on
n'a pas les temps mais il a mis quatre
ou cinq minutes un coup qu'il aurait
joué en plie c'est sûr parce que c'est
un réflexe je vous l'avais montré ce A4
donc clairement c'est pas impressionnant
au niveau gestion du temps
mais voilà c'est comme ça
le champion de chaise tours génération
Julius berkup le tournoi est terminé
streamlabs qui nous met des petites
annonces là le tournoi est terminé de ce
juste père avec un corps une victoire de
manuscrit la division 2 Yann les
premiers emporter donc il est qualifié
avec un match face à firoga qui a tenu
toutes ces promesses au premier match du
champ emporter et le deuxième match on a
eu droit à un Armageddon très très chaud
que Magnus Carlsen a encore une nouvelle
fois à emportée mais
clairement à lire ETA qui a fait un très
très beau tournoi avec cette deuxième
place qui avait lieu 4 c'est tout à fait
normal on veut jouer F5 et on veut cette
structure de type Stonewall vous avez
comment jouer avec le Stonewall par
minus Carlsen sur chaise 24
pour les chanceux qui sont encore
premium magnifique vidéo
tournée tourner chez lui avec des notes
que j'avais fait des petites notes pour
ce pour cette vidéo série
et il explique avec sa compréhension qui
est pas mal hein de manière générale un
peu les Stonewall cette structure de
pion si particulière et là on a le fou
en dehors donc c'est clair c'est un bon
deal pour les pour les pour les Noirs
d'habitude on a le fond en C8 c'est pas
trop quoi en faire en général histoire
par B6 x 6 mais là s'il est sorti la
structure de pion F5 est clairement un
coup alors si on prend ici puis on prend
qui est des deux et là on va simplement
prendre prise F5 alors vous me dirigez
et puis on doubler certes mais bon c'est
quand même assez agressif on va pouvoir
faire 5 bon ça c'est intéressant
mais c'est clairement la façon de
réfuter sur sur cavalier 4 c'est la
prise parce que si on laisse si on
laisse faire F5 on va pas être bien
et oui on a la cam et oui bapoudou 69 on
a la cam on a les droits on a les droits
alors je sais pas pourquoi on a les
droits mais en tout cas on a la cam et
ça ça fait plaisir à toutes les cames
d'ailleurs je vais vous faire un petit
est-ce que
hop là on a la deuxième cam là vous
voyez on a une cam sur chaque échec et
je monte mes skins on a la troisième
c'est goûté je contredoussa torov
et vous pouvez voir la salle de jeux la
troisième gamer face à regga Easy oui
les joueurs hyper focus et la dernière
rajabov face à
je suis désolé je m'excuse et Maxime ma
chérie évidemment façade et donc c'est
sympa on a les 5 cam on peut choisir
pour pas cher je sais pas franchement
c'est vrai j'arrête évidemment
des droits pour pas cher mais là je sais
pas du tout
et tant mieux c'est pour un plus grand
plaisir
il y a pas moyen Raja en Raja ça faisait
longtemps qu'on l'avait pas vu c'est
vrai c'est vrai Raja bof il a joué la
Coupe du monde quand même mais pas
longtemps il a perdu contre je sais plus
contre qui l'a perdu il a perdu assez
tôt c'était une première surprise
ouais
d'accord mais on verra là parce que là
ça se il se passe des choses quand même
quand il prend puis on prend que des
deux je vous en parler il faut prendre
deux il va jouer 5 c'est le seul coup
pour pas perdre le pion
et F5 F5 va être joué F5 a été joué par
le champion français
et maintenant c'était attendu de
refusation peut-être F3
peut-être que c'est 4 j'en sais rien
comment on fait ici
comment on fait avec les Blancs c'est
intéressant cette position la joie
j'aime bien les blancs
bon ça me saute pas aux yeux pour être
tout à fait honnête
peut-être une petite tactique les Noirs
veulent faire le 5 si on fait le 5 tout
va bien 31 empêche 5
[Musique]
surtout on prend je fais pas qu'elle est
propre parce qu'il y aura une découverte
je fais dames
mais j'ai l'impression que tu as raison
à cause de kfc4 celui de la poussée par
exemple je vais là et on pousse le pion
puis on passait la tour derrière c'est
chaud quand même
donc toi viens peut-être mais tout va
bien un peu bizarre quand on a joué à 4
donc réflexion chez Kichu qui a plus que
8 minutes contre 12
ouais bah non mais c'est pas
compréhensible là la gestion du temps de
Sacha greichu même lui il comprend pas
donc t'inquiète pas
ne t'inquiète pas
cette coupe du monde je vais rejouer je
vais essayer mais je vais essayer déjà
le prochain étape ça sera essayé de se
qualifier pour la dernière étape du
champions qui sera évidemment à suivre
sur chaise comme
je sais pas comment elle s'appelle mais
en tout cas il y a le play-in le 18
septembre et en cas de calife c'est du
25 au 29 septembre donc ça sera à suivre
sur cheescom
la dernière étape de ce champion de
chaise tour avant la grande finale
évidemment donc voilà on va essayer de
se requalifier
pour ce champion de chez toi
F3 jouer par Alexander greachuk très
logique on casse
la structure de pion après on est sûr
que les noirs peuvent pas jouer de 5
donc les blancs sont un petit peu mieux
pourquoi parce qu'elles se pion aussi
qui peut être faible on peut on peut
imaginer un dame F2 suite un doublement
des tours
et sur F3 apparemment peut-être il y a 5
qui marche ah 5 Alain de marcher la
jauge ne Mouv' pas trop qui est C4 à ce
moment là je fais dame 6 quelque chose
comme ça et c'est vrai que sur pion
prend et puis on prend et voilà on voit
tout des tours qui travaillent là on est
on serait pas mal
voyez on va prendre les deux colonnes
ouvertes donc F3 E5 c'est un coup
c'est un coup MVLS j'ai envie de dire un
coup dynamique comment on en a fait plus
perfectionniste oui c'est sûr c'est sûr
que quelque chose qui est
perfectionniste procrastinateur aussi
5 jouets
et maintenant alors il y a des chances
que ça se liquide par exemple qui est C4
dame aussi ça ne met donc aller prank et
prend puis on prend de me prendre bon
honnêtement ça peut être très marrant là
ça risque de faire nul on va faire puis
on prend la tour ici on va essayer de
faire ça peut-être dame 3 mais
franchement c'est quand même très très
équilibré tout ça
donc on va voir pourquoi
ça me peut-être que ça peut être la
partie la plus spectaculaire de la
journée
prochaine fois les candidat c'est
je crois que c'est en avril 2024 ou juin
2024 enfin c'est des débuts premier
semestre du 24
ouais le looser bracket ouais c'est pas
mal cette histoire de looser bracket moi
j'aime bien en fait l'idée qu'on puisse
se refaire qu'une défaite soit pas il
est complètement illuminatoire
effectivement quand on est à loser
bracket on mange un peu son panoir faut
quand même gagner plus de match
effectivement mais bon on a perdu un
match aussi normalement on devrait être
éliminer
alors qu'elle est C4 il va il est en
train de choisir une casse pour la dame
a priori on choisit une case où on va
contrôler la case des 5 ça c'est
important pour pas qu'il y ait des
quatre dessins donc ça va être soit
Dame des 5 on peut l'occuper aussi au
lieu de la contrôler j'aime pas parce
que je perd un pion peut-être puis on
prend puis on prend comment on fait
il aime pas ah mais non je fais caméléon
3 attaque la dame et ensuite je vais
pousser par des quatre des cinq je
rappelle que vous avez l'évaluation vous
avez à droite la barre mais je n'ai pas
les coups des variantes donc j'essaie de
deviner avec vous c'est plus sympa donc
Dame des cinq ça serait une faute semble
très très
normalise pour empêcher des cinq tout en
contrôlant ce pion je vois pas où est le
problème honnêtement
je n'aime pas ah bon
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle veut faire je
dame D8 peut-être de me D8 continue à
faire pression sur ce pion et c'est vrai
que sur puis on prend qui avait les
prend
qui prend tout reprend c'est vrai que
surtout ADN on aura des MB6 tout le
temps
donc tout va bien et si on prend ici
d'abord attention à des choses comme ça
comme cahier des trois qui peuvent faire
très mal
suite si on prend le 4
Dame des 7 paraît pas mal ouais oui dame
D8 plus logique non dames c'est 7 j'aime
pas proposer un chat parce que il y a
des 5 ça marche pas
et on crée un pion passé pour les blancs
donc ça ça me semble pas terrible
quoique il y a peut-être pump
donc je sais pas
aussi intéressant possible avec cette
idée sur des 5 puis on prend et d'un
prend c'est ce qui doit être en train de
regarder dame prend et maintenant on va
peut-être enfin on peut avoir ça peut
être très dangereux dans cette position
c'est très à double tranchant avec ses
pions qui font
comment elle pourrait-il se qualifier au
candidat il a des chances étoiles
Laurent Jules et bac pro alors ouais
alors sa meilleure chance ça sera le
grand Suisse qui arrive à l'île de Man
qui est fin octobre
j'ai passé mon tour
pour ce tournoi pour cette open
de Man je ne vais que où le soleil va
donc je quand il pleut quand on prenait
de la pluie pendant 15 jours je n'y vais
pas
mais par contre Jul joue et Étienne
Macron joue ça sera évidemment à suivre
sur chaise com
et Maxime Vacher La Grave et à lire les
affaires rouges ça sera un peu une sorte
de dernière chance même si elle est
Raisa garde des champs sous l'eau
donc de toute façon
les Français sont bien représentés au
rang des chances il y a deux places à
prendre et ça sera un peu ouais ça sera
la dernière chance pour mvl Jules et
Étienne donc est-ce que Ali résa aura
aussi
une chance ou alors clairement parce que
il y a beaucoup de gens comme karwana
qui sont très bien en vélo mais qui sont
déjà qualifiés pour la Coupe du monde
donc à suivre à suivre tout ça on espère
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas avoir deux
représentants français ça serait énorme
ouais c'est vrai qu'elle a été énorme
l'année dernière dans ce tournoi grand
Suisse il a décidé de zapper la Coupe du
monde
bon c'est un choix
quels sont les enjeux de ce tournoi
c'est un beau tournoi
l'argent
et les prix et des points lourds en
partie rapide et Blitz mais ça reste un
grand tournoi un petit peu hein tata
style vous connaissez c'est un peu
c'est le frère c'est le tournoi frère de
du tata style avec André qui à droite de
partie classique et là c'est un tour de
rapides donc on a simplement un beau
tournoi avec les Indiens et celui qui
gagne quand même c'est pas rien de gagne
à toi comme ça
il est en train de provoquer Sacha il
est clairement pas d'accord pour faire
pour faire nul comme ça il a calculé
Maxime et il a calculé avec la précision
qu'on lui connaît quand il est en forme
donc très intéressant ce début de
tournoi
allez le jouer Maxime qui veut
clairement pas assécher la position il
provoque il provoque gritchouk et il a
envie de de marquer un point de cette
première ronde on va voir
ce qui se passe évidemment vous aurez
tous les résultats en temps réel on va
on va suivre tout ça on fera un petit
point classement à chaque fois quelque
chose qui a pris en E5 et prend le 5 a
été bits c'est cavalier prend et un
petit peu le il met un coup de frein
getchup tu reprends le 5 jouer mais
c'est plus confortable pour les Noirs
alors la jauge je ne m'ouvre pas
évidemment pour la jauge tout est simple
clairement
et oui j'ai déjà battu mvl
tonne 13.015 j'ai battumpel dans toutes
les cadences possibles et imaginables
j'ai battu un verre en partie classique
en partie rapide et en blitz
en partie classique c'est pas glorieux
c'était en
2012 2004
2004 il a 14 ans
j'avais profité pour notre première
partie officielle en particulier
classique j'avais perdu que deux depuis
ça va je menais deux en Ultra Bullet non
alors j'ai battu au championnat de
France en 2004
je l'ai battu en rapide au moins
Villandry en plus c'est pas sûr j'ai
battu enfin parti à Mika j'ai battu
plein de fois j'avais perdu beaucoup
plus évidemment mais en partie Blitz
officiel on a dû jouer une fois aux
champignons de Bleach j'ai perdu mais
pas plus
en 2004 il est terminé il était déjà
grand maître quand même je veux bien
enfin il était quand même
non il était pas grand maître
hein
j'ai battu plein de fois quand même
quand il avait 2007 plein de fois un
petit peu mais j'ai battu je me rappelle
de Nancy de Villandry donc j'ai battu
quelques fois
tout à fait Starfix
est-ce que tu as un jeu que deux depuis
alors non bah pour du 69 non non Maxime
plus de 10 c'est sûr une quinzaine je
pense il est beaucoup beaucoup de nuls
tu sais c'est le résultat quand même ouh
là
c'est le résultat
c'est le résultat quand même le plus
probable
nul quand une partie est pas trop mal
jouée un peu comme on dit 1743 bon
ouh là oui ou là j'ai vu la blague oui
oui j'ai compris la blague
ouais bon on la laisse
je passe de faire ses blagues ou pas
je sais pas je te laisse responsable
alors dam F2 jouer et on a 6 minutes 40
contre 5,50 alors
effectivement
ça paraît assez égal mais attention
attention le roi un petit peu faible ces
trois contes 2 là qui offre toujours des
perspectives
au noir mais effectivement ça manque de
pièces mineures tout ça ça manque de
pièces en général d'un F2 on regarde un
petit œil ici il veut évidemment
échanger une paire de tour quelque chose
qui est en mode défense clairement
qui est pas contre une nul
et c'est le résultat
quasi quasi certain ici très honnêtement
parce que ça manque de matériel tout ça
mais on va voir on va voir si Maxime va
continuer à essayer de poser problème ou
pas
alors
ah Maxime Le National quand même en 2004
c'était son premier national d'ailleurs
son baptême du feu
donc il était déjà quand même on sentait
que ça allait être à la Nouvelle Star
donc on s'applique non c'est bon là
parce qu'on sait que ça peut être la
dernière victoire effectivement je
m'étais pas trompé à ce niveau là
ça a été ça a été la dernière victoire
j'ai beaucoup les Noirs contre Maxime
faut dire aussi mais bon
mais beaucoup souffert beaucoup souffert
beaucoup de nuls mais beaucoup de nuls
en souffrance pour prendre un et à 6
jouer je vous l'avais dit ce pion qui
était en l'air
bon si on échange les dames voilà si les
dames sont échangées c'est nul 100%
parce que c'est final de tour c'est
archi archi nul
donc clairement
[Musique]
clairement c'est l'objectif des blancs
qui sont à mon avis un tantinet moins
bien parce que cette majorité elle va
être très dure à pousser
est un disque le roi quand même peut
être pris à partir après un 4 F3 quelque
chose comme ça ouais j'ai fait
disparaître plus de plus de 1000 Blitz
avec Maxime machinagrave donc oui oui on
peut appeler ça comme ça
donc ouais énormément de parties
d'entraînement
évidemment
avec avec la mie Maxime qui est
redoutable qui était redoutable qu'il
est toujours qu'il est encore plus parce
qu'il a expérience en plus maintenant
il était déjà vif d'une vif d'une
vivacité assez hallucinante en blitz
mais là il a il a doublé ça avec une
expérience du jeu
et
expérience de ces grands tournois voilà
il peut jouer un peu plus vite un peu
plus solide parfois enfin bon il fait
tout un peu mieux quoi voilà donc il a
fait des gros progrès notamment à
travers sa pratique dans les dans les
grands tournois ça y est rien de mieux
donc là maintenant il est il est juste
un jouable
salut sanguine le Baron Noir
alors que va nous faire quelque chose
qu'il a joué à 6
getchouk oui j'ai
soucis à régler pour notre ami Sacha
comment on fait peut-être un coup d'âme
F3 pour venir là centraliser un petit
peu la dame on sent que la dame elle est
quand même pas extraordinaire F2 donc va
falloir peut-être faire un coup de un
coup de centralisation
des centaines avec Magnus mais moi
sur une game ouais sur une game bien sûr
une game oui bien sûr bien sûr que c'est
une game je peux
bien sûr sur une game il peut tout se
passer évidemment
mais voilà sur un match je parle de deux
matchs
avec mvl je n'ai absolument aucune
chance de de faire plus de 50%
aucune
sur un blitz évidemment sur deux blits
même pourquoi pas sur 10 non H3 petite
case pour le roi prenez note
H6 et oui
très
un peu c'est je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui m'avait
ce que le singe voit
ça fait il parlait de il parlait de lui
et il paraît il parlait des joueurs
d'échec en général il disait que en
général après H3 et vous le remarquerez
dans vos parties en général le coup le
plus fréquent c'est H6 voilà dans ce
genre de position où il fait H3 une
petite case c'est pas bête ça H6 voilà
et roche va-t-il faire à fuite on attend
le roi
Monkey is monkey
ou pas
on va voir
est-ce qu'il va pas faire Maxime
peut-être un petit coup de F4 là
peut-être un truc ici pour faire F4 F3
intéressant
ah ouais je sais pas ce que c'est pour
les propositions de nul mais bon de
toute façon rapide et pas trop de
problèmes sur ce genre de choses mais
clairement il y a des joueurs combatifs
en plus
bon là c'est vrai qu'il y a pas grand
chose honnêtement mais bon c'est ton
jamais que la pendule de Sacha 3 24 mais
bon il y a 10 secondes par coup je crois
qu'il est arrivé alors trop de respect
pour pour que tout pour essayer de
l'emporter
je serais tenté par un MC6 mais c'est
vrai qu'après par exemple la même dame
F3 je vois pas trop ce que je fais pour
être très important V7 et si Dame prend
F3 comme je vous l'expliquais et puis on
prend ce genre de final c'est
complètement nul il y a aucune chance de
gagner que ce soit pour les blancs pour
les noirs
ouh là ça va prendre les 600 secondes
attention
alors
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
ouais change de gagner je parle de ce
niveau là de ces joueurs avec une telle
technique on rappelle
je rappelle que tu es considéré en tout
cas au début des années 2000 comme le
futur champion du monde par les Russes
donc clairement un talent
un talent qui est pas venu complètement
complètement à terme même si une
carrière absolument fantastique mais un
joueur qui aurait mérité par exemple un
match champion du monde clairement
il fait B5 petites attaques de minorité
mais il croit pas un maximum le voit
dans son body language comme on dit on
voit
ça va être nul je vais vous laisser la
caméra on va aller voir une autre partie
parce que là c'est c'est nul c'est sûr
c'est sûr ma mère ma main la main droite
à main droite a coupé que ça fait nul
aucune chance
les deux joueurs même
des cinq jouets
qui est une quasi proposition de nulle
regardez regardez il va jouer danse 4 je
le connais
je le connais
et
de la tête tu parles il va prendre
prise je vous donne la fin de la partie
tout au 5 il va jouer roi là pour C5
tomber 8 ton français 4 on prend le
allez vous l'aurez vu ici en premier
Alexander parce qu'il est pas mieux
le formol allez-y
4 et tout au 5 regardez regardez
regardez il hésite mais non on le sait
moi je le sais vous le savez maintenant
tout le monde le sait
tout le monde le sait et voilà dame
prend ses quatre puis on prend ces
quatre et tout ça et regardez regardez
ça y est c'est la position sur les
chéquier on va me prendre tout rose 5
roi G6 annoncé par textes
et sur tous ces cinq tomber 8 je lis
tous les chats
je fais pour en technique
regardez moi j'ai 6 jouets vous l'aurez
vu ici en premier et oui c'est annoncé
Roger 6 tours ces 5 va être joué ton C5
tour V8 va être joué oh là là regardez
ça quand même si c'est pas franchement
franchement je alors à mes heures
perdues je prédis l'avenir aussi
je tire les cartes enfin je fais ce
genre de choses
voilà il y a pas de problème si vous
avez des si vous voulez savoir ce qui va
se passer dans votre vie sur les 10
prochaines années n'hésitez pas à me
contacter
tarif est cher mais bon bon ça va faire
nul évidemment ce 3 contre 3 c'est comme
une séance 6 du 25 + 10 donc ça dépend
quand elle est partie se termine on voit
les deux joueurs qui se respecte
beaucoup trop on va aller voir si on n'a
pas une autre partie à se mettre sous la
dent
qu'est-ce qui se passe là non non non
c'est pas bon ça allait partir on va les
prendre là alors qu'est-ce qu'on a écrit
China moi j'ai envie de voir évidemment
Google Google
chez Maxime ça fait nul les deux joueurs
savent pas comment se départager mais il
y a même pas il y a aucun suspense on va
voir Google
on va les trouver goketh face à abdos à
torov on a eu une espagnole mais là on a
beaucoup de combat c'était vraiment
les deux joueurs grosse forme un goût
cash numéro 1 dire et à d'où ça t'auras
ancien champion du monde de partir
rapide de jeunes stars qui ont vraiment
le vent en poupe tout simplement
et qu'est-ce que ça donne cette position
apparemment les noirs sont mieux et où
il a peur de fou qui tape sur le rock
adverse de 25 entre une 14 on va avoir
du
du spectacle ici
quelles sont les cartes de backi pour
les candidats
ah ça va être compliqué
ça
va être compliqué ça arrive tout le
respect du avec qui il faut qu'il faut
qu'il termine avec deux premiers de du
Grand Suisse
moi je vous dis allez ça va se qualifier
quand même
pour Maxime il faut que je me concentre
pour donner une réponse claire à
définitive aussi
la qualifier les deux victoires de
livraison aux candidats voilà
entendu ici en premier
alors on voit les deux fous qui tapent
avec la dame
et une partie une partie assez assez
solide de la part de Maxime
qui a pas qui essaie de mettre un peu la
pression sur quelque chose mais qui a
pas tenté le diable non plus première
ronde c'est les plus dures on se met
dedans petite nul avec les Noirs contre
joueurs qui a une
certaine classe évidemment enfin une
grande classe quelque chose
donc on va voir ça
non je remets pas à main à couper cette
prédiction
bah qui mvl qualifié au grand Suisse
mais le grand Suisse Reiki je crois que
tu te rends pas compte du niveau là
ça vaut une cote que les deux soient
qualifiés
c'est quand même assez hallucinant c'est
très dur c'est très dur faut gagner
beaucoup de parties mais bon on verra le
livebox vous montre toujours derrière la
partie entre grishuk et mvl
[Musique]
mais on va peut-être changer est-ce que
la nuit a été signé non
d'accord
vous avez la partie là-bas devant une
interdiction de proposer nulle très
certainement
et on voit qu'il est 7 tours à 6 jouets
on va essayer de mettre les chic et en
plus grand je vais vous changer la scène
ça va être
ça va être énorme
non du coup je vais faire ça
ouais parce que là on voit plus le de
toute façon on n'aura pas le temps de
suivre X8 jouer par
abusa torov une 30 contre 50 secondes
ça va être passionnant cette fin de
partie évidemment il y a les 10 secondes
par coup qui laissent quand même le
temps de respirer un petit peu mais
attention attention j'ai l'impression
qu'il menace ce 4 et peut-être une
découverte parce que vous voyez la tour
derrière très très complexe cette
position tour à 5 on attaque un petit
peu ici on essaie de divertir les les
Noirs parce que franchement
sur le long terme on est mal avec les
Blancs clairement il y a de fou hein et
de fou pour les Noirs les noirs sont
mieux il y a pas de problème pour B8 il
protège son pion gentiment on a le
centre on a la paire de fou on est très
très bien on a un potentiel d'attaque
assez assez conséquent avec ce roi qui
est très faible en géant
et Manu ça dit que le format il faut le
format changer
alors bien sûr bien sûr il est aux
échecs t'inquiète pas pour lui
dorék moi t'en fais pas pour t'inquiète
pas inquiète pas plutôt pour nous pour
toi pour moi pour les gens du chat
t'inquiète pas trop pour Magnus allez
en général
cloner ce genre de de de
joueurs de personnes de sportif ils s'en
sortent en général ils s'en sortent bien
t'inquiète pas ils savent ce qu'ils font
attention
ça chauffe H4 c'était pour mettre
certainement un cavalier ici mais bon on
va pas trop ça va tout raciste attention
on veut créer le clouage mais on se crée
aussi de 4 fois H2 peut-être pas ici
parce que ça ferait quand même beaucoup
de jeux fous B7
oustes
le pion
et d'un goût qui ok pour la nul hein qui
est beaucoup moins bien ici donc il va
pas
chipoter kf6 à petit à petit surtout
promet ça qui a F3 on gagne du
matériel on menace maths et si on
reprend F3 on fait tour reprend tour et
c'est terminé
et il sacrifie la qualité notre ami
Google il a bien raison
parce qu'il est pas bien ok j'ai 4 qui
est arrivé donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
bien on doit reprendre de la dame on est
moins bien ça c'est sûr mais bon c'est
une chance pratique de changer le
caractère de la position comme ça quand
il y a ce peu de temps c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt une bonne idée
oui pour mvl tout à fait tout à fait nul
dans cette première ronde il y a trois
aujourd'hui je vous le rappelle
alors tu reprends le 5 a priori il faut
prendre à moins qu'un coup comme tout
revu puisse marcher je crois pas mais on
peut aussi décider que le non non dame
prend il m'inquiète très logique
attaquer F2 à ta que 5 c'est 2 joueurs
que vous retrouverez lors du speech la
compétition chez com
vous les retrouverez évidemment Google
mvl Magnus Carlsen Iker unakamura
bref tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde
en blitz les prochaines parties sont à
13h à 14h30 je n'en sais rien gros bien
je pense que je sais pas j'ai pas le
programme on va le savoir
je suppose que oui peut-être que c'est
toutes les deux heures en fait parce que
c'est vrai que dame prend c'est tout
pour F3 et tour C8 attention attaque le
pion c'est
et attention c'est pas simplement le
pion c'est c'est aussi le fou attaquer
le match du couloir comment il fait il
est il est mal il est mal notre ami
google
va être très certainement être joué
attaque le fou très désagréable cette
position pour les blancs voir
complètement foutu il y a des thèmes de
maths du couloir évidemment la dame pour
l'instant garde la la cassé un mais bon
pour prendre C3 fouder un jouet
je peux même vous mettre nos
commentateurs cam full screen Player et
regarder et non et regardez ce que je
vous mets full screen le fameux le
fameux full screen tours français 3D 1
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué là j'ai pas le ça
va se mettre
fouder un tour prends des trois et feux
de vous pouvez suivre sur le petit écran
voilà les deux joueurs à fond est-ce que
vous aimez bien cette vie ou pas Tourbet
3 on menace mate attention on met à se
mettre en B1 ce pion est aussi en prison
une qualité sèche de plus ouh là là
Google malgré tout le talent de ce jeune
homme je crois que c'est terminé car de
son cuites d'un B6 aussi peut menacer
attaquer F2 c'est un désastre
il a joué quoi
et là ouh là là ça pue le coup de massue
c'est un coup de masse ou un truc comme
ça peut-être
peut-être menace de me prendre la Store
prend on joue sur le clouage ça a l'air
tellement gagnant cette histoire et
attention les dernières solides et nos
amis jouer mais la soucis demain pour
faire son premier fosse c'est
complètement terminé
dans ces quatre a l'air d'être le seul
coup alors dame c'est 4 jouets
ils sont forts moi je vous le dis
en faisant une remarque désagréable et
oui on adore
alors comment on fait maintenant pour le
donner le coup de grâce je n'en sais
rien ce serait typiquement ils sont du
rabattre hein c'est typiquement leur
gros point fort moi je vous le dis
Google
c'est que pour les battre et bien faut
se lever de bonheur avoir une bonne
position ça peut arriver mais alors les
battre c'est autre chose il se débattent
jusqu'au dernier souffle
ils sont incroyables pour C8 je pense
qu'il y avait des problèmes avec un Mac
du couloir peut-être tu reprends 5 je
sais pas
Dame des 6 ou attention ou attention
alerte menace ce matin attaque le
cavalier je crois KF3 et le seul coup
KF3 jouer ça tient encore il est
incroyable ils sont incroyable ces
joueurs parce qu'ils se battent jusqu'au
dernier souffle
c'est complètement incroyable
comment on va faire
alors
qu'est-ce qu'on joue
c'est pas non plus d'où ça te renvoyer
la résilience c'est la grande qualité de
ces jeunes joueurs
ils sont ils sont très très durs et
voyez vous cache qui se bat
combien on aurait ce serait dit bon
foutu c'est foutu je joue un coup puis
on va abandonner mdr encloud c'est pas
grave pour les blancs il faut avouer
faut avouer qu'elle est pas facile à
jouer cette position la dame doit garder
le contrôle du fou le fou est cloué le
Calet peut pas trop bouger faut jouer un
coup de tour lequel peut-être est-ce que
tu reprends en marche
et donc on prend F5
parce qu'il y a tout reprend et on
aurait dame C8 mais il y a dames prend
F1 intermédiaire et ça serait terminé ça
me prend F1 tours F1
tours de plus alors qu'est-ce qu'il a
joué
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué notre ami il
réfléchit toujours
il réfléchit toujours après dame dire
tourner Dame des trois MB2 attaque F2
une fois de plus oh là il est là il est
là il est là
et vas-y que je te redends un coup à
gauche un coup à droite attention au
pion j'essaie de carotter le pion quoi
que pas sûr il y a plus on rêve derrière
ah je sais pas ce que je ferais là je
suis en panique intégrale
comment ça se passe là sur quelle idée
de
tourner un on joue le clouage chez
gookes
comment il fait maintenant
comment il fait tourner attention
menacerait quand même là il veut il joue
ton profil
il veut mettre des perpettes un thème de
mc8 M5
et oui il faut pas laisser traîner avec
ses joueurs là ils peuvent prendre un
pion il le prenne
alors maintenant et il joue calife 6
coups du retour et c'est pas bon du tout
mais il attaque ici je vois pas la
réputation je vois pas la réputation
il joue qu'elle sait 4 oh là là c'est
bien joué ça parce qu'il attaque la
dernière oh là là vous allez dire ils
ont ils ont ils ont mis le vif ces
joueurs là ils ont mis le vies même si
un jouet et dame de jouer et tout 8 et
vas-y je te remets un coup qu'est-ce qui
va jouer il va jouer tout au 5 qu'est-ce
qu'il peut faire d'autre cavalier 3
peut-être
cavalier envisagé regardez comment il se
défend c'est c'est assez fort
j'aime pas tout rec5 j'aurais plutôt
qu'avec les trois tours 5 j'ai
l'impression qu'on prend et on va jouer
tout roule 1 ça va être compliqué
qu'est-ce qui va jouer gooche et il a
joué tous vos cinq il me fait mentir lui
il suit pas son intuition et calcule
c'est quand même une différence
alors tout 5 et maintenant
comment on fait comment on fait et bien
j'en sais rien j'en sais rien on va
laisser répondre
il est fort il est fort
il est fort il sait pas faire et
attention les joueurs qui jouent sur la
carie ça c'est le coup du retour ça son
aveu d'échec mais bon il reste quand
même mieux enfin voilà la jauge mais non
la jauge dit également mais vous
inquiétez pas qu'elle est dur à jouer
cette position quelle eau trois tours
des deux quoi que ça pourrait être
complètement tourné avec si peu de temps
tourner de jouer attention à ce petit
pion F2 mais il me semble quand même
globalement c'est quand même les les
noirs qui poussent clairement
même C4 et ouais il pensait gagner cette
partie il est aussi étonné mais lui il
est pareil il y a aussi teigneux que
l'autre les deux attention c'est ils
sont ils sont aussi durs à battre
dame prend ah et là il échange Hassan
aveux de d'échec en mode ok maintenant
on fait nul
mvl ça a donné nul dans cette première
partie cavalier 3 jouer et maintenant
c'est trop solide
c'est trop solide il est même plus mieux
à tour des quatre attaque les deux pions
bon je retire ce que j'ai dit
alors est-ce qu'il va pousser son pion B
il espion ou protéger espion et son
pionber ça c'est une grosse décision moi
franchement
j'aurais pas quoi faire contre un joueur
moins fort je garderai mon vieux contre
un joueur plus fort je regarderai mon
prochain
est-ce qu'ils sont certes plus fort au
moins fort
je pense
que ouais il a l'air il a l'air pensif
et il joue voilà j'ai trois bon ben il
joue à nul j'ai trois tours des 4 et
tout F5 jouer en protège F2 attention
énorme menace cahier des cinq et il joue
tour des 8 il a envie de s'organiser par
là des choses comme ça
pas si facile encore pour les noirs
sur XOS pour le temps pour le temps on a
notre Patrice Laffont pour nous informer
ah c'est vrai que vous voyez la pendule
bref il joue sur les secondes 40
secondes
franchement je pourrais vous mettre le
temps sinon voilà est-ce que je fais une
prouesse technique ou pas est-ce que je
tente la prouesse technique
est-ce que je tente pour cette technique
de mettre le temps
vous allez rien voir non
vous allez les
le temps va il joue sur un crémant voilà
alors et fousser 4 jouer ton bébé 2 en
double
il faut 6 pardon bref
et on va laisser suivre ça et encore une
petite un petit exercice de défendre
mais de défense à faire clairement
mais attendez je vais remettre live
voilà j'ai deux et on va voir les coûts
donc ça paraît très solide est-ce qu'il
y a pas un coup de cavalier 4 à un
moment non tour des 8 vient et de jouer
cavalier ok il y avait tout fuite et
faux F5 est-ce que je raconte donc ça
marchait pas du tout
ça va faire nul on apprend qu'on aura
déjà bof sinon si vous voulez aller voir
le jeune le jeune indien on va on va
faire ça on va aller voir pragraja bof
pas grave j'abof ils sont là non il a
gagné Prague il a gagné on revient chez
on va revenir chez nos amis à moins
qu'on aille voir avec le chat parce que
ça ça va faire nul on viendra plus tard
tranquille le défonce d'accord
on va aller voir ce que ça donne chez
visite et il a l'air d'avoir un pion de
plus
on va regarder ça tout de suite je vais
vous le mettre
chez Vidy pardon
c'est dommage quand même chez vidite hop
là
alors le temps
40 secondes pour éviter 43 secondes pour
écrire ça dans l'autre ça devrait faire
nul est-ce qu'il va réussir à avoir la
[Musique]
la
torfu qu'on tourne c'est la principale
question je ne crois pas mais c'est pas
sûr et salut tout ouf je trouve qu'on
retrouve je crois ce soir j'ai regardé
j'ai regardé mais je me souviens plus
dedans oh là là c'est terrible ça c'est
la mémoire je crois que c'est 20h les
vents a rognan
je crois je crois les von Aronian en
speech
sous contre Aronian c'est dans 7 heures
et 18 minutes et donc c'est donc à 20h
j'avais raison on retrouvera ce tour je
suppose je crois
sauf qu'il fait ce soir donc saut à
rognan
du speech bon ça va faire nul dans
l'autre ça s'énerve
on va aller voir nos amis Abdou et
Abdou et Google qui défend toujours je
vais vous remettre la partie
donc à partir de 20h ce soir vous aurez
vous aurez cette
ce match très sympa ah c'est en train de
répéter entre les deux joueurs nul nul
ok je reviens au mauvais moment à moi
qui joue la gagne alors peut-être mais
non
mais non c'est énorme
c'est énorme
nul
nulle aussi chez vidite ça fait nul je
crois que tous les parties sont
terminées
je crois
est-ce que je me trompe on va aller
faire un petit tour
ouais tout est terminé on va essayer de
regarder les résultats non les résultats
d'abord
Alexandre Richou face à Maxime va chez
La Grave ça a donné nul dans la première
agrishna visite nul comme on l'a vu
goûter shadowsator off quelle défense de
gouquettes vous avez vu ça ah c'est dur
à cuire dans cet endroit c'est pas
facile de mettre un point et il a pas
réussi à d'où ça tof gamer abattu Hardy
le local et programmer le récent
finaliste de la Coupe du Monde a battu
tes mouradjabov
les standings
un point c'est facile
ceux qui ont pas gagné
ils ont zéro ceux qui ont perdu et ceux
qui ont fait nul ils ont un demi alors
je vais rappeler le format
comme ça en plein écran
alors le format comment ça se passe
9 parties parties particules en 25 + 10
c'est le jour 1 aujourd'hui on en joue
trois aujourd'hui on a l'impression de
jouer que tellement les vies c'est
rapide donc trois rapides aujourd'hui 3
rapides demain 11h30 tous les jours
trois rapides après demain et là après
on passe au bled à la cadence de 5 + 3
pas sur
mais a priori ça va être ça les deux
derniers jours donc Hobbit on est quel
jour aujourd'hui on est mardi demain on
est mercredi jeudi vendredi samedi on a
du Blitz c'est sur tout le monde joue
tout le monde est-ce que les points vont
compter double ou pas
je pense que les points ont compté
double sur le plan parce que j'ai pas un
truc moi
j'ai pas le format mais je crois que les
points vont compter double par rapport
au Blitz
voilà je crois
ça me semblerait logique à moins que ça
soit un point pour tout on verra tout ça
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'à priori les rapides vont compter
pour plus cher que les que les Blitz
est-ce que quelqu'un de cheesecom la
connaît la règle s'il vous plaît Nathan
Samy
bouftouf je connais peut-être
mais pourquoi pas Kevin sérieux tant
qu'on est une période c'est sûrement vu
qu'il a pas la relève alors
alors on va faire ça on va voir voilà on
voit que on a la nul qui est-ce qu'on
aura dans cette deuxième partie on va
aller voir les appareils en peut-être je
vais vous mettre ça je vous mets des
appareils
regardez
regardez regardez ça c'est moi ça non on
va pas me regarder on va faire
regarde
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe ah ben
regardez on va regarder le
format regardez on va faire le format
alors 25 + 10 je vous fais le format
pendant la pause 25 + 10 le contrôle de
temps 3 + 2 en blitz on joue OK
OK
le
tournoi en fait il y a deux tournois
il y a deux tours
et un tournoi de Blitz
ok intéressant
est-ce que le ton
player single Rand Robin
je crois que en fait il y a simplement
quatre jours ce qui est double
on va voir donc en fait c'est deux
tournois séparés dans quel tournoi de
partir rapide et ensuite de tout droit
de partie Bleach il y a pas de il y a
pas de combiné
intéressant donc voilà c'est bon
maintenant je connais tout le tout le
format
on va regarder maintenant non on va
faire les parties et cette rentrée
hop là en
bas alors
pas les appareils
on vient de découvrir
mais bon
je t'ai vu encore sa couette
Antoine j'ai 33 et ben allez on a passé
un bon moment
salut amical à nos amis corses qui nous
regardent nombreux je le sais et très
très bien les tournois je ne peux que
recommander le soleil
les échecs la bonne humeur la magagne il
y a tout
contre qui joue Maxime Vacher la grave
dans cette deuxième ronde attendez je
vais regarder
on va regarder puisque personne n'est
capable de donner l'info
alors
ah regardez je sais en fait si je
regardez je vais vous changer ça
hop regardez-moi ça
regardez vous allez être épaté je vous
préviens asiez-vous les appareils
membres de la ronde 2
sont là Maxime avec les Blancs
entrepreneurs on est arrivé l'un de l'a
fait
ensuite on a gamer Raja bof et non j'ai
mieux que ça chez ce come fr j'avais
oublié qu'il fait en fait j'avais un
truc tout près et à la place du 1 faut
que je mette le 2 j'avais oublié gamer
ajabov abdousator
le très très grand format c'est notre
ami mvl
face à
abdoussa torov masquée les parties
terminées hop là
du coup il y a plus de partie
donc ce qu'on va faire
c'est que je vais vous laisser attendez
on va faire on va pas faire ça ensuite
tu vas partir
on voit je vous laisse ça je fais une
petite pub
je trouve qu'il dit d'ailleurs tu
m'avais battu à gwenza alors c'était
vers 2011 tu t'en souviens sûrement pas
exact
c'est je suis très content de la prendre
mais je m'en souviens pas du tout
mon cher stuff
désolé
j'ai joué plein de fois
à coince j'ai gagné d'ailleurs une fois
je crois pas tant que ça donc du coup le
priceful le price full il est pas mal à
mon avis il alors le priceful on
regardera une autre pause mais vous
inquiétez pas pour eux si s'il y a des
plus souvent des starting fille donc le
price poule est sympa en général
dans le genre de tournoi les joueurs
font le déplacement et tout ça donc
c'est sympa je vais faire une petite
pause et je reviens pour la deuxième
partie qui est à mon avis va commencer à
13h
on est d'accord sur ça
je crois que tout le monde est d'accord
et
on se retrouve sur ravi de vous
retrouver encore deux parties
aujourd'hui et puis 5 jours de Live
souffle dis-nous si ce soir tu l'as dit
tout à l'heure
plutôt que de parler de tes défaites oh
là là
parle pas de tes défaites
sauf qu'on félicite évidemment avec son
son titre de
et dis-nous si on se retrouve ce soir à
20h pour le match ce soir on y a c'est
une très très oui 20h d'accord soit
rognan beau match du 5 + 1h30 5 + 1 une
heure de trois plus un et une demi-heure
de un plus un
sauf favoris évidemment contre les von
mais attention c'est chaud allez je vous
retrouve à tout de suite merci d'être là
restez avec moi tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les titles
tuesday.com/avent scoop tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts
et même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs émoticônes et les emoji
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts et les animations spéciales
restent sur les chéquier jusqu'à ce
qu'elle soit effacées pour ce faire il
suffit de cliquer avec le bouton gauche
de la souris sur les mots J ou de
cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
et je suis de retour pour suivre ce
stata style chess India rapide and blues
donc en deux tournois séparés
et nous avons le droit de partir rapide
on va voir qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
dans cette première ronde et bien
aussi Maxime va chez Lagrave le héros
national le héros d'un peuple
the French guy with to name
lui a donné ce surnom
qui a fait une nulle très solide face à
Alexandrine chou comme un bon début de
tournoi avec les Noirs contre grishuk
et on va voir
tout de suite pour la deuxième partie on
va évidemment suivre cette partie entre
on va regarder les appareils
qu'on a envie de voir le jeune star
indienne qui a fait un parcours
formidable
à la Coupe du Monde de s'incline en
finale face à Magnus Carsen et gagnant
son ticket pour les prochains candidats
et oui et oui à simplement 18 ans ou 17
je sais pas quel âge il a il est trop
jeune de toute façon enfin il est très
jeune trop non
pas trop jeune mais il est très jeune ça
c'est sûr
il doit avoir 18 ans après un DA et on
va avoir la petite partie on va se
mettre les chéquier bien comme il faut
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est la cam 1 non
la gamme de non plus
et oui ah on a le monsieur là l'arbitre
l'arbitre
on sort du champ monsieur l'arbitre on
ne voit rien
ça lui Fontenoy 56 salut Bruno
on va voir Maxime Vacher La Grave allez
il a eu 18 ans
bon voilà 18 ans l'avenir lui appartient
prendre un comme Google peut-être les
deux plus brillants représentants
de cette génération je vais changer le
c'est génération indienne avec
évidemment
avec évidemment
[Musique]
Eric easy aussi qui est pas mal non plus
hein et on a recrishna alors attendez je
vais changer ça je vais changer la
partie aussi la petite partie que vous
pouvez suivre et
voilà normalement ça doit marcher vous
avez comme d'habitude oh à gauche le
liveboard où vous réfléchissez à votre
rythme et tout ça et à droite le où je
fais des flèches encore une flèche on
arrive en faire bosser pour mon life
time répertoire oh la vache oh la tuile
oh ils vont me réfuter mon répertoire ok
il est 5 puis on prend et dans mon
répertoire je vais recommander cavalier
7 et 8 ouf
j'ai cru qu'ils allaient encore me
donner du travail je recommanderais
kARIO 7 qui est un coup plus agressif
que kb8 a dit de venir F5 ensuite
je vais le montrer qu'avait le 7 son
F500 en G6 et ensuite de monter une
attaque à El roi ça sent un répertoire
d'attaque
et aussi assez et le coup classique
évidemment l'autre coup à 4 et full 7 on
va jouer petit rock les blancs font en
général fouet 2 et petit rock aussi
suite faut 3 on a une majorité à l'aile
dame pour les blancs tandises
pour les Noirs c'est pour ça que je vais
recommander cavalier 7 parce qu'il me
semble c'est plus logique de mettre le
cavalier là où on va attaquer mais bon
côté à la logique
ouais alors là mat mat 49 73 oui bien
sûr c'est tout le monde quand il y a une
variante aussi chaude évidemment c'est
qu'est-ce qui fait mat il est très au
point on a vu dans ce match entre Magnus
Carlsen et Fabiano car on a de 2018
cette variante avec kd5 sur la chaise
nikov apparaît trois fois sur échiquier
en particulier une fois en partie rapide
et évidemment tout le monde travaille à
ce moment-là à ce moment-là tout le
monde regarde on essaie de venir avec
nos idées et Daniel duboff nous avait
Cavalo 7 qui était il a joué ça dans la
douzième partie Magnus Carlsen
qui a joué deux fois kb8 avant et qui a
eu le 7 il a joué ça à la 12e partie
plus dans la partie de départage et donc
c'était le coup le plus agressif le coup
la signature d'un île de bof
donc clairement tout le monde
tout le monde essaie de travailler sur
ça en fait c'est tout mon travail sur ça
parce que c'est la vente critique la
vente qui nous faisait peur celle qui
essaie de réfuter le concept des Noirs
fouf c'est un coq F5 donc il veut mettre
le fou par là le cavalier par là et
ensuite éventuellement vous voyez son
pion intéressant la part de Prague
donc est-ce qu'on fait à 5 d'abord
est-ce qu'on rock d'abord
là je sais plus trop ce qu'il faut faire
j'ai déjà vu ce fou F5 mais franchement
mes souvenirs sont quand même assez
assez lointain
on va voir ça va être une belle partie a
priori parce que vous voyez ce coup de
cahier des cinq crée des déséquilibres
inhérents à la position
notamment au niveau de la structure de
pions et les pions
sont l'âme des échecs
donc c'est très important cette
structure de pion qui va pas pouvoir
être changé et donc on a cette majorité
à l'aile dame contre cette majorité elle
roi donc clairement les forces noires
vont se diriger vers les Leroy
normalement tout en prévenant aussi
essayant de retarder
la TAC l'attaque à l'aile à l'aile dame
des blancs des blancs parce que c'est
vrai que si on laisse faire si on laisse
faire tout gratuitement
ça va pas aller tout à fait
tout à fait je vois qu'on
connaissait classique et merci piercée
de nous rejoindre sur Youtube et twitch
n'hésitez pas
si vous appréciez cela
vous abonner à la chaîne mettre un petit
pouce petit pouce bleu les pouces bleus
vous abonner à la chaîne comme ça vous
ne ratez rien de toutes nos
retransmission l'actualité est chargée
en ce moment entre le speech et ce Tata
Steel India le champions qui reprend à
partir du 18 septembre avec la calife et
le 25 avec les tournois en mode
septembre voilà avec pas mal d'animation
on suit évidemment sur chaise com
tous les plus grands tournois je pense
qu'on peut nous voir aussi sur chaise 24
n'hésitez pas si vous êtes sur chaise 24
en train de nous regarder
à venir
sur à vous abonner à cheescom parce que
à terme il y a quand même des chances
que tout ça
tout ça se passe sur sur chaise comme
quoi que j'en sais rien en fait
j'en sais rien mais bon voilà
d'où vous soyez abonnez-vous voilà et
aux réseaux sociaux aussi n'hésitez pas
les réseaux sociaux ou tout est annoncé
vous voyez ce matin il y a un petit
tweet de chasse comme à faire pour
annoncer
pour annoncer ce beau tournoi avec
Maxime
on encourage pratique
et il est 7 ok intéressant
en retard assise un petit peu ce
cavalière en général vient à trois et
ensuite en C4 et on va s'occuper de la
case de B6 donc on retarde au maximum à
6 mais c'est un coup qu'on va jouer
certainement
c'est pas un pur isolé au centre Catus
94 qui nous dit qu'elle est plus en
isolée c'est pas plus isolé parce que
papy isolé c'est un pion qui n'a pas de
partenaire sur les colonnes adjacentes
je crois je crois que c'est ça la
définition donc là il va pouvoir être
protégé donc il y a pas de pion isolé
donc
concrètement le plan des Noirs il se
passe aller droit il se passe par là E4
cavale 5 ou alors full g6f5 ou alors un
moment faut que j'essaye il fait à 5 à 5
menacé à 6 donc il fait à 6 là vous
allez voir certainement cavaliers à 3
jouer assez rapidement par Maxime il va
chez Lagrave pour venir en C4 c'est le
coup logique
il réfléchit un petit peu bon mais il se
met à partir
définition de Yannick Pelletier ouais
congénère pas partenaire autant pour moi
alors
tour C8 ouais c'est encore principal ici
mais je vois un peu tous les messages de
Youtube et
de twitch donc n'hésitez pas selon votre
convenance
où est-ce que vous préférez suivre tout
ça
ouais on va pas se fâcher avec la Suisse
bon c'est dur ce vache avec la Suisse
tour C8
jouer par Maxime Vacher la grave
et on voit cette case V6 mais attention
elle est contrôlée par le cahier des 7
donc effectivement on peut pas sortir
avec ce cahier des 7 mais
il est tenu un peu à la défense de cette
case B6 donc on peut pas y aller tout de
suite mais il est quand même tenu donc
voilà vous voyez ça a double tranchant
c'est toujours plus complexe que ce
qu'on pense
comment on va faire ici avec les noirs
a priori il faut que je Cisse celui de
F5 je rappelle la cadence c'est du 25 +
10 Maxime qui permet de se lever
et salut à toi iron King 37
comment on fait ici mais j'en sais rien
on peut pas faire fouger 5
ça n'irait pas du tout
donc il faut soit trouver un moyen a
priori moins le coup qui me vient c'est
ça quand même c'est ça et ça
parce que ou alors un petit coup de dame
C7 mais ça a l'air d'aller dans la
mauvaise direction quand même
globalement
donc je pense pas que ça aille
honnêtement
qui a gagné mvl ou Sacha personne
nul solide
système de l'entrée aucun problème pour
Maxime qui a essayé de chatouiller un
tout petit peu
greachu mais qui a pas réussi
et maintenant c'est l'heure du plan pour
Prague qui dépense son temps
au bon moment tout simplement et on
rappelle on l'a vu en rapide éliminer
Nakamura Fabiano Carana il était énorme
en Coupe du Monde il est très fort à
quelques secondes à la pendule donc il a
pas du tout peur de se mettre mal au
temps
est-ce que B5 est intéressant non pas du
tout B5 ne marche quasiment jamais on
joue du côté des blancs là c'est en
général très mauvais quand on fait ça
déjà
[Applaudissements]
donc ça n'irait pas B5 clairement ça
sera pas joué
honnêtement je vois pas je vois pas faut
prendre ces deux une option non pas du
tout
pas du tout pas du tout parce que j'ai
de me prendre tout simplement et il y a
pas de moyen de tirer profit du coupage
exactement même sans clouage c'est vrai
après A6 et C6 sont faibles donc on a
faibli éventuellement créer à 5 et là il
y a un problème concret sur le pire de 5
et le puronc à 6 alors c'est vrai qu'on
pouvait contre-attaquer on peut dire
oui certes mais par exemple 3 voilà
attaque le fou même ça c'est bien pour
les blancs parce qu'on va encaisser à 6
on attaque le fou on protège ses deux on
protège des cinq avec notre cavalier
et donc voilà ça n'irait pas donc là il
fait tous ces 7 Prague et alors là
et alors là
je sais pas il va faire dame C8
certainement mais il y a toujours B3
franchement c'est assez
ça c'est mystérieux
ce coup de Tours c'est 7 à mon avis
j'aime pas j'aime pas du tout bon là
jauge n'a pas l'air très inquiète c'est
vrai qu'on pouvait imaginer des tours à
3 et c'est vrai qu'après dame C8
on va être obligé de protéger B3 et
voyez la tour on avait l'idée de passer
la tour eh bien on peut plus le faire
aussi ça l'idée
alors est-ce qu'on peut faire foudre 3
moi il faut 3 un coup
faut 3 et un coup mais qu'est-ce qu'on
menace
je sais pas ce qu'on menace parce que
kb6 c'est jamais une option à cause de
ce pion peut-être ces trois B4 d'abord
faire ensuite mais enfin c'est pas
évident
ouais
je crois pas jusqu'au pire soit on prend
mais bon ça a quand même un peu libéré
les noirs pour envisager F5 ensuite on
peut faire le 4 et gagner du temps sur
le fou
donc j'y crois pas faut des trois par
contre alors j'y crois pas c'est
toujours pareil est-ce que les Blancs
veulent pas jouer au H1 F4 qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec les Blancs c'est ça la
question aussi
elle est elle est très complexe
stratégiquement c'est cette position
parce que d'un côté on a quand même
envie de jouer à Elda mais là on voit
que les noirs sont en train de
s'organiser pour empêcher le contre jeu
des blancs à l'aile à l'aile dame enfin
le jeu tout simplement pas le contre jeu
et donc c'est vrai qu'on peut prendre le
le contre-pied de tout ça et faire un
roi H1 F4
qui avait le 3 j'aime pas trop
G6 et ensuite on va faire F5 F4 donc je
trouve pas ça extraordinaire
physique slow qui nous dit est-ce qu'on
en sait plus sur un de Maxime que disent
les rumeurs
je vais pas vous dire les rumeurs
je peux pas vous dire les rumeurs
les rumeurs
les rumeurs restent des rumeurs salut de
le dire ou pas on va le savoir bientôt
je pense
alors Maxime
pas selon mes infos voilà je répondrai
plus maintenant
je ne répondrai plus
pas selon mes infos mais bon les rumeurs
c'est ça le problème il y a toujours un
soupçon de vérité dans les rumeurs ouf
ça c'est pas sûr
c'est jamais sûr ça ça dépend des
rumeurs
c'est bottes
ok ok game on
pensait roche pour faire F4 mais c'est
vrai un coup automatique c'est vrai
qu'il se passe pas grand chose sur cette
grande diagonale il y a pas trop
d'échecs donc F4 est intéressant
et Laurent Blanc peut-être
et ouais Laurent Blanc il va plus avoir
de travail Laurent Blanc donc il
pourrait faire un bon candidat
alors F4 a priori au 4 est assez mauvais
parce que 3 et probable G6 maintenant il
y a F5
on perd une pièce donc à priori on va
quand même être très très obligé de
prendre
moins que G6 soit un coup non j'y crois
pas je crois qu'on va être obligé de
prendre
du coup Maxime qu'est-ce qu'il veut
faire je pense qu'il va reprendre du Fou
et attention attention pion des
c'est chaud
donc F4 a priori puis on prend à l'air
vraiment d'être le seul coup est-ce que
Prague va me faire mentir parce que
évidemment la menace et puis on prend et
voyez la tour qui attaque le fou
un coup comme ça même si oui qui protège
voyez directement le truc ah mais non
non ça marche pas puis on prend qu'elle
prend
sera en l'air donc ça n'irait pas
donc F4
et maintenant
voilà Laurent Blanc le nouvel entraîneur
de Maxime Vacher Lagrave dans quelques
jours
faut aller sur X ex X
forcément ce nouveau nom j'arrive pas à
me faire
donc F4 attaque puis on prend puis on
prend pas notre coup hein
ce qui a fait beaucoup d'après comment
il joue ces jeunes et il joue pas les
coups forcés ils réfléchissent au coup
d'après
fou G4 acrobatique
mais bon
ce qu'on y croit à ça on va donner la
paire de fou ça a pas l'air terrible
ouais
Laurent Blanc
il a un nom de ce genre d'échec
oui bien vu voilà
il fait chier à ça
j'avais pas vu
tout à fait c'est ça la réflexion
intéressant
et maintenant sur
puis on prend on fait que attention de
pas reprendre du pion sur un problème
ici
mais on reprend du cavalier
et là c'est chaud
s'il y a pas un petit fou français de
l'intermédiaire
alors peut-être et puis on prend et ça
va pas pour les blancs
donc faut quatre intéressants attaquent
des cinq directement ah plus je regarde
plus ça me plaît
qui B6 non j'aime pas que je prends
prise et même je peux me attaquer ces
deux
bien très bien vu
très bien vu
comment s'appelle notre ami
Mathieu Rodriguez sur YouTube
il faut 4 attaques le pion des
comment on joue là je sais même pas
comment
il faut des trois il faut prendre
avec les Blancs et donc F3 il y a un
problème sur le problème de surcharge
à très intéressant
ça peut être très chaud c'est pour ça
qu'il a fait chier autant Prague mais
maintenant on peut prendre ici peut-être
pour prendre
6 peut-être attaque des cinq protège des
que c'est chaud c'est très chaud cette
position
3 j'aime pas trop parce que simplement
je vais prendre ici après fouger 5 ça va
être chaud pour les noirs pour les
blancs
F4 fois 4 jouer par le jeune Prague
après une longue réflexion 17 minutes
contre 1945
intéressant
ouais
c'est juste pour booster vous pouvez me
suivre n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur
Twitter et attention j'ai notif donc je
verrai les
les petits
les petits menteurs n'hésitez pas à me
suivre sur X vous aurez bientôt le nom
en exclusivité de l'entraîneur de Maxime
machinagrave
sachant que les promesses n'engagent que
ceux qui les entendent vous me suivez
déjà bon
[Musique]
c'est trois peut-être aussi parce que
vous
c'est 3 est un coup en force plus ou
moins on menace de prendre donc on force
plus ou moins la prise
on n'a pas de Dame des 4 il y a cavalier
F6 toujours juste à temps pour protéger
et le mat et le fou
et si on fait tourner
5 a été joué par Maxime qui
qui peut qui joue direct de sa manière
assez habituelle
il aime bien les échecs concrets notre
ami Maxime bon là a priori on va
reprendre
il a fait Chypre
il réfléchit à quoi il réfléchit encore
une fois et ils sont forts ces jeunes je
sais j'arrive même pas à dire à quoi il
réfléchit à chaque fois qu'elle prend 5
et Maxime balade un petit peu vous le
voyez alors il fait ça tout le temps
c'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout pour dire que Prague
est un poireau
et prends jouer puis on prend il va
jouer C4 il croit en sa majorité
ok ok
pour moi j'ai dit tout à l'heure oui
évidemment que vous pensez de mettre
jouer
évidemment ouais moi je suis d'accord
ouais j'aime bien les Noirs là faut
prendre ses deux bien sûr ça va être
joué pourquoi pas un pion comme ça
gratuit Maxime il prendrait
et oui parce qu'après et puis on prend
on laisse quand même cette phalange
alors
cette phalange qui est quand même assez
belle il y a pas de raison que on prenne
pas le pur d'abord
ouais moi j'aime
j'aime pas du tout la position de Maxime
après
il a dû voir quelque chose après la dame
vous pensez de jouer
attention pas du Royal à la fourchette
on prend du fou car il est aussi c'est
nul en gros
ça va faire
Maxime Vacher la grave sur ton point F7
on bouge la dame c'est aussi à peu près
équilibré quoi que
ton premier
ça peut être chaud tout ça
et après
qui est déjà ambitieux je trouve ça joue
rapidement c'est un coup qui montre une
certaine ambition
bah écoutez il y a déjà gagné la
première mais non content de ça il veut
il veut continuer
il veut continuer sur sa lancée
c'est tout lui ça
alors
Maxime qui se lève beaucoup là
ouais 4 était un peu un peu tôt
mais c'est pas évident c'est pas évident
clairement
pour l'instant on est parti quand même
assez tranquille qui a notre ami Maxime
qui arrive pas à mettre le feu non c'est
position un petit peu oui il est quand
même un des meilleurs joueurs du monde
ou voir le meilleur dans les positions
ou c'est le chaos général faut H4 jouer
pas mal fois 4 j'aime bien j'avais pas
vu et maintenant je le vois je l'aime
bien j'ai trois jouets tempo et oui on
touche la dame et c'est vrai qu'on
affaiblit un petit peu le roi le roi
blanc en faisant ce genre de choses
toujours très intéressant
et sur G3 il va revenir tranquillement
très certainement un F6 et toucher B2
ou prendre la fin d'abord je sais pas
puis on peut faible non ça va mais c'est
réglé les pièces noires on le sent vous
voyez les pièces noires elles sont quand
même sur des colonnes ouvertes
ce fou va pouvoir être très actif en F6
je suppose quoique j'arrive pas à
deviner un coup le fou en CD pas le
placer il pourra venir en E4
alors c'est clair que
l'avantage il y a rien de tangible
encore pour les Noirs mais
potentiellement ça peut ça peut mal
tourner et je crois sur G3 j'ai 3 y
réfléchi
exactement je suis nouveau dans les
échecs nous dit Schwarzy 32 comment se
passe les tournois classement tout à
fait il y a un classement il y a du cash
price tout à fait et en général il y a
aussi un starting fille de moins en
moins
sortis pour participer au tournoi on ne
donnera pas la même chose à Magnus
Carlsen qu'à moi-même par exemple ça
coûte ça coûte plus cher de m'inviter à
un tournoi que d'habiter manus Carlsen
c'est ça le concept un peu comme dans
tous les dans tous les sports un petit
peu comme ça tennis individuel quoi que
je sais pas s'il y a des starting fille
au tennis
il y a tellement pris que je sais pas si
Federer il touche un petit billet quand
il va à Wimbledon ou pas
j'en sais rien honnêtement
donc ça dépend des tournois chacun
chaque organisateur fait ce qu'il veut
pour les compétitions de la fidélité là
c'est très clair les prix sont affichés
et en général il y a pas de c'est sûr il
n'y a pas de starting fille les prix
sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
certaines filles c'est un cachet
caché pour se rendre au tournoi
non ils sont pas du tout
non non
je sais bien Thomas latin mais
est-ce que Federer a pas par exemple
quelque chose pour jouer au début voilà
et le classement comme au tennis à peu
près oui ça marche à peu près comme ça
là c'est un classement de partir rapide
et de partie Bleach donc c'est un peu
différent il y a aussi le classement de
parties rapides de parties classiques
pardon
docteur bilbas
salut mon cher
c'est quoi le starting FIP pour l'avoir
pour t'avoir en National aucune
transparence sur ça je préfère le dire
tout de suite
c'était très très cher
dans le chat salut à tous 33
qui est un bien beau château notre ami
va tout 33
excellent joueur de tennis
on verra on verra
on va faire le spectacle au tennis et
oui bientôt
bientôt
pour changer ton pseudo on va tout 33
meilleur pseudo que ça quand même
récemment alors j'ai trois jouets et
plus de 10 minutes pour Prague je vous
l'ai dit il a pas du tout peur de jouer
avec ce très peu de temps parce que
c'est vrai que c'est coup qui joue avec
10 secondes effectivement moi si je veux
les mêmes je serai pas inquiet il faut
F6 jouer bah c'était le coup qu'on a
envie de jouer en premier pourquoi ça
replace le four on échange pas les tours
parce que si on échangeait tout en
facilite quand même un petit peu la
tâche des blancs qui sont un peu plus
passifs on attaque le pion gentiment et
on dit à Maxime écoute qu'as-tu prévu
maintenant
comment tu fais pour protéger tout ça
peut-être fouger 4 fois aussi c'est
quelque chose d'actif à la maxime
voir les fous des quatre échecs aussi
pas être chaud
et oui sinon oui au niveau amateur
évidemment
on paye en PC inscription pour jouer le
tournoi comme ça hobby c'est ça le truc
comme au tennis je prenais mes
inscriptions pour jouer le tournoi
alors
il réfléchit Maxime et elle est pas
évidente cette position parce que le
pion be traîne
il faut mettre comme dirait Magnus
Carson dans ce genre de position
il faut mettre un coup de frein
c'est malheureux à dire mais on en est
au 21e coup avec les blancs mais là
c'est
c'est clairement l'heure du coup de
frein il faut essayer de jouer de jouer
de viser le partage du point sur un bon
deal pour les pour les blancs les blancs
sont un petit peu moins bien clairement
j'ai été 30 au maximum
big jeterne mais là j'ai perdu là je
dois jouer à 32 33
ça fait joue plus je joue plus
donc
proposé ça dans le chat tous ces trois
il faut prendre ces trois puis on prend
ces trois
tours F1 non non
par exemple tu reprends F1 faut prendre
F1 alors là j'ai les chèques j'ai du bol
mais vous voyez un coup de tour c'est 5
par exemple admettons dans un monde où
tout va bien j'attaque ici j'attaque ici
on voit les faiblesses du côté blanc qui
peuvent
ils peuvent poser problème bon là il y
aurait certainement dame aussi tout
droit quelque chose comme ça et
effectivement le Roi peut être prêt à
partir c'est pour ça que ces trois et
peut-être pas mal donc faut ces trois
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à part
prendre ces trois je vois pas grand
chose d'autre donc vous prend puis on
prend
et maintenant peut-être un clouage ou
alors je sais pas ce qu'on peut faire
peut-être un coup de dames pour menacer
de venir ici chaque fois que je joue un
coup là je n'aime pas
si je n'aime pas qu'est-ce que je vous
dise moi
4 valeurs des fois 5 il faut faire
attention peut-être fou le cas des
choses comme ça intéressant
ou alors un petit coup de tour reprend
il faut prendre et on va remettre la
tour par là
on va s'organiser on va essayer de
s'organiser comme ça mais alors j'aime
pas voyage à chaque fois je propose un
coup je trouve pas ça extraordinaire
donc peut-être tout recettes mais
j'aimais bien vous voyez cette tour elle
est active quand même donc j'aime bien
les changer quoi que d'un meuf2 je vais
m'en pressé de jouer il y a quand même
le pion qui traîne qu'on laisse pas
traîner ici on joue Dame des deux par
exemple mais ces trois me semble être un
très bon coup et je vois honnêtement si
vous voyez un autre coup
je suis je suis preneur
on va utiliser la technologie Full
stream pour les dernières instants pour
l'instant on fait avec ma tête pas très
agréable
le liveboard à ma gauche pardon à ma
gauche le liveboard vous pouvez à votre
rythme regardez tout ce qui se passe
évidemment à droite vous avez les
chéquier où je vous montre tout ce qui
se passe et le coup qui va être joué pas
fou des trois fous ces trois a priori je
vois pas notre coup en fait c'est ça qui
me
qui m'interpelle mais bon Maxime est-ce
que j'ai 4 est un coup
pour aller sur fouder 4 on vient
où on vient là plutôt attention il y a
des scénarios cauchemars comme ça vous
voyez quatre là ça peut faire très mal
un truc comme ça ça va pas du tout
c'est une jauge raisonnable c'est un
jauge de chaise haute com donc
elle nous bat tous vous inquiétez pas
pour la jauge elle bat aussi
mvl et Prague
j'ai pas mauvaise on va pas commencer à
s'inquiéter pour la jauge
vous voyez
pas très agréable tout ça
va pas aller
comment on fait ici ça me semble pas
évident peut-être Dame des deux mais
alors c'est un peu capillotracté
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joué il a joué 4
Maxime ma chérie ok ok 14 minutes contre
il cherche du contre-jeu il est pas en
mode en mode je me défends et j'attends
que ça aille mieux
intéressant
elles sont dures à jouer c'est position
une tendance évidemment très amusante
parce que dès que par exemple deux
paires de Tours vont s'échanger ça sera
quand même très très nul tout ça
donc
des quatre jouets roi G2 ça peut être
très compliqué mais ça peut aussi se
simplifier
plus vite qu'on ne le pense
a priori on prend ici alors attendez si
je prends on va prendre la dame faut 4
on veut quoi
on veut ça non mais non Maxime
on n'aime pas ça on aime pas ça mais je
crois qu'on va le faire
qu'est-ce qui se passe si je prends le
pion j'ai raté une tactique
ou pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe Dame des trois
dame FC
3 parce que là
ça devient plus compliqué d'ailleurs un
gain à mon avis c'est tour à 4 le gars
on attaque ici et il y a le foulard non
c'est pas toi
c'est pénible cette jauge hein
on fait quoi
toujours pas tourner
la meuf si c'est maintenant le coup de
massue
je vois pas le coup de massue
oui même en ayant l'indication c'est pas
simple
c'est pas simple du tout
je sais pas ce qu'il faut faire
je triche mais je vous le dis Tour
Eiffel dame 5 c'est quoi le coup il faut
F4 là qu'il y a
sur la 4 dame prend fou prends faut
aussi trois chute
ça ne va pas
ok donc
ton premier fun après a été joué donc
apparemment le pion est prenable mais il
faut faire très attention il faut 4 h 3
va jouer sur five 3 F7 à mon avis
j'ai vu que c'était chèque
toi F7 c'est prends ton temps ça se
tient ce genre de truc mais bon pas très
marrant
puis là pas vraiment vraiment parce
qu'on va perdre B2 le roi est trop
ouvert il y a les dames sur la chéquier
ça va pas donc sur tout prendre à me
prendre je pense que sur fou et 4
ça va être beau
il réfléchit Prague sur cette position
après d'un point F1 elle est
intéressante effectivement faut qu'il
fasse un peu attention au temps il a
pendule mais bon ils sont tellement
forts et si peu de temps
comment il va faire ici
je sais pas leur tour Eiffel serait le
coup désirable évidemment mais un gros
problème
donc c'est le coup qu'on a envie de
jouer mais on peut pas le faire
échec et le deuxième coup qu'on a envie
de jouer clairement et ça j'ai pas ah
j'ai ça encore vraiment
non on va être cloué ça c'est le truc à
être cloué éternellement
ça ne va pas du tout
donc
non ça ça n'irait pas
F4 il veut
alors encore une fois
un truc comme ça c'est ça
intéressant intéressant intéressant
cette position puis on prend un peu mais
c'est très très chaud
attaque le pion
voilà et il a joué un autre coup oh là
là faut
pas laisser traîner
faut prendre mes deux jouets
incroyable
prise de risque de Prague mais bon en
même temps et puis on traîne il le prend
c'est lui ça
effectivement cette chose qu'il faut
c'est un peu tout
à la joie qui estimait à je sais pas
c'est là elle doit être à 3300
les meilleurs ordis sont à 3500 vous
voyez 3300 ça laisse de la marge par
rapport même par rapport à Magnus ça
laisse quand même pas mal de marge
donc faut prendre les deux la tour et
attaquée
est-ce que avant de bouger cette tour on
collerait pas un petit échec
intermédiaire
quoique il va pas s'envoler donc on peut
commencer peut-être par tout un tour à
deux je vois pas trop à quoi ça sert à
toi mal placé ici on va simplement
reculer le fou
a l'air très très logique
et
et intéressant
en tout cas à l'air d'être le coup pas
si intéressant mais en tout cas c'est
très probablement le coup
comment on va faire
qu'on va faire avec les Blancs pour
Maxime qui réfléchit et c'est un bon
moment vous voyez Maxime qui joue un peu
vite qui joue plus vite que son
adversaire mais ça lui permet aussi
d'avoir
plus de temps dans les moments critiques
comme ça faut aussi intermédiaire ouais
faut aussi s'intermédiaire ouais je suis
et maintenant
est-ce que j'ai 5 intermédiaires
pour jouer sur ce fameux du couloir il
faut prendre il y aurait de la fuite
ça me prend on va le montrer
effectivement
on va devoir bouger cette dame
certainement ici quelque chose comme ça
les échecs ici ou alors échec d'abord
intermédiaire qui peut être pénible sur
H3 madame 8
et pourquoi pas jouer
par mvl
et le coup logique que je vous annonçais
il faut F6 c'est vrai que c'est pas mal
il faut F6 ça permet de
de fermer un petit peu la diagonale de
fermer la pardon
la colonne effectivement éviter ce genre
de d'inconvénients de matin du coup
donc Maxime mais bon un peu de jeu il a
réussi à activer ses pièces un pion
quand même
donc je sais pas
bien du coup un petit coup sur
c'est marrant je vois pas du tout jouer
FF6 et je fais 6
il me fait mentir
Prague F6 parce que ça me semblait un
peu trop un peu trop sûr
et je pensais que il voulait
tout recettes aussi
il aurait été plus ambitieux en plus
pour les Noirs les Blancs souffrent
et compensation sont pas évidentes alors
évidemment c'est dur à valoriser ce pur
en plus parce que comme on fait pour
pousser le pion B alors que les blancs
vont prendre en passant à chaque fois
donc c'est complexe
mais Maxime un peu dans le dur là un peu
moins bien
clairement il y a pas photo
comment on fait surf 6
x 3 pour jouer
mais tout recettes de toute façon je
vais y aller
justement j'y allais
effectivement on va se très beau fou
aussi qui va apporter quand même
quelques compensations mais c'est quand
même un pion c'est pas un grand c'est
pas un gros pion mais c'est un pion
comment il va faire Maxime ce qu'on fait
les chèques d'abord est-ce qu'on essaie
de replacer ce fou d'abord
je vois pas de le problème c'est que le
problème le problème de la position
blanche c'est que les noirs n'ont pas de
en pâte faiblesse à part une faiblesse
par la faiblesse du roi noir
potentiellement qui peut se retrouver
sur des attaques
et il faut 3 jouer et pas Maxime va chez
La Grave
avec la menace pas discrète du tout donc
il fait pas ça du tout pour ça
ouais c'est fou se replace en E3 il va
perdre B6 mais surtout recette il va
faire ici surtout
c'est ça
c'est ça le
faut trois fou c'est 3 attention on joue
avec le feu là
faut aussi se croiser 6 ça c'est chaud
parce que maintenant faut prendre on
peut pas prendre ici il y a maths
donc ça ça peut être très chaud pour
pour programmer mon avis il va pas faire
ça
il va pas bouger son fou ça m'étonnerait
je vois bien jouer
tout recettes plutôt
cette position 5-40 simplement pour
Prague mais bon on sait qu'avec peu de
temps
c'est moche de moi qui a suivi ce match
en direct je t'en remercie je sais j'ai
eu des copies d'écran
de tes messages sur
dans cette génération Cup où j'ai cru
que je pouvais gagner via le taux
contraint non j'ai pas cru que je
pouvais gagner une fier de toi j'ai cru
que je pouvais ne pas la perdre bon
évidemment je donne un peu en début de
la finale ce qui marche pas et après il
a montré cette technique infaillible
artemief il a été il a été très bon il y
a rien à dire j'ai fait une gaffe
tactique qui permet un pion
ça coûte cher on peut pas faire ce genre
de choses face à des joueurs
d'une aussi grande qualité
faut trois et fou G6 vas-y je t'encule
les fous alors vous allez me dire oh là
là il y a pas vu et il a tout vu
il a tout vu
dans ces deux échecs on se déclou et
ensuite on va bouger cette dame alors où
c'est un détail à voir
mais en tout cas c'est ça le concept
mauvais jour pour égayer apparemment
nous dit-on c'est possible à très très
combatif prend beaucoup de risques
prends énormément de risques et donc ça
peut aussi parfois donner des résultats
moins bons
je sais sur le corps
je l'ai commenté suffisamment souvent
pour pour le savoir mais bon si je te
dise
facile à dire
après à éviter bon là j'ai perdu un pion
vraiment bêtement
je pense que si je perds papillon je la
perte pas bon après
tu peux me dire le contraire et moi
aussi et donc bon on saura jamais quoi
alors qu'est-ce qu'il va faire Maxime
sur fogé 6 8 48 contre 5 minutes
et calcule et calcul
ça ou ça
quoi d'autre
quoi d'autre honnêtement
c'est où est-ce qu'on espère ce sauver
est-ce qu'on peut sauver comme ça
au moins on échange
alors c'est pas glorieux on est d'accord
mais bon là on est en train de on est en
train d'essayer de sauver sa peau
on s'amuse les gens sont capables de
faire une partie entière alors c'est peu
mais beaucoup à la fois à ce niveau oui
bah oui on voit comment il joue en
Bullet on a vu le super le truc le
Bullet de Championship sur chetcom là
c'était quand même
c'était assez dingue au niveau des
parties
roi je crois il a joué non
non
c'est un peu lunaire
elle est un peu en retard
non il a joué
je crois que c'est très bien que il faut
qu'il se déforme maintenant et surtout
ces deux il va jouer tous deux à mon
avis et vous voyez prend son temps à
chaque fois Prague je peux pas les
couettes tempo là je là j'aimerais bien
qu'il me dise qu'elle est l'autre coup à
part tour C2 ils jouent tous ces deux
échecs OK
et est-ce que Maxime va essayer de
changer les pièces moi ce que je ferais
parce que franchement
quoi d'autre
il faut changer les pièces parce que les
finales de fou
elles vont être nulles parce que
à la fin il y a des chances qu'on puisse
attaquer les pions
est très active de toute façon c'est pas
mal de changer quand même
on va voir
Maxime qui a l'air de s'apprêter à jouer
un coup
je sais pas
honnêtement
c'est pas clair ce qui va faire pour moi
quoi tout deux quand même c'est
tellement
c'est tellement cool ici
alors on va voir la prochaine partie
alors j'essaie de
il est quoi 13h48 là
ils ont commencé à 13h je crois que ça
va être 15h la prochaine
ça dépend aussi de la fin des parties je
pense qu'il y a un quart de pause et
c'est mérité parce que c'est intense
mine de rien c'est c'est tournois et
c'est parti en 25 + 10 tours de jouer
par Maxime mais un petit coup de frein
là avec champion de moi quoi d'autre il
faut attendre c'est comme ça c'est
malheureux mais évidemment on espère on
préfère une victoire avec les blancs
mais ça se passe mal
tour de feu 4 et jouable oui tout à fait
faut calme mais on H3
et il y a un problème avec la dame
apparemment
et le fou par exemple sur dame 7 il y a
fou aussi c'est chèques maintenant
attaque le roi donc on doit bouger et
hop on encaisse le fou
j'ai l'impression qu'il va s'en sortir
Maxime
admettons un truc comme ça
quand je fais nul
parce que c'est sûr que ça fait un truc
tu es trop F3 là pour empêcher fou et 4
et mener assez fou ces 8 B7 et x 6
intéressant
il a joué tout reprendre et dans ma
fuite il veut garder les dames parce que
cette fille de fou elle serait nulle
bien joué de la part de Prague
qui pour l'instant domine son sujet
alors clairement sans être écrasant
cette partie c'est lui qui a des chances
de guerre
donc belle partie après sa première
victoire contre les noirs
puisqu'il a montré la Coupe du monde
j'ai l'impression qu'il est favori quand
même de cet endroit
il y a tellement de bons joueurs comme
gouquettes ou comme
et comme
[Musique]
ouais c'est vrai qu'on a raison
ça faisait mieux je pense parce que je
mettais le foot par là
bon je perds cette mais je perds je
perds un combat mais pas la guerre donc
je perds mais pas si donc ça doit faire
nul encore
presque gagnant je reconnais là ton
optimisme
donc dans mes fuites il jouait il joue
la Gan évidemment Prague il aurait tort
de se priver
un petit coup de fouet
il a 18 ans Prague Google je crois
Abdou ça
dans 20 ans
même gamer attention gamer je ne
génération
bon bref c'est à toi très ouvert de
toute façon c'est souvent le cas quand
il y a pas des monstres comme comme
icarbonaka Moura ou ou Magnus Carlson
dans ces cas dans cela en tout cas qui
en général laisse des MI attend
là le tournoi est très très ouvert et un
peu plus âgé peut-être qu'il a 18 aussi
ou 19 je sais pas
dimanche
ils sont tous hyper jeune hyper
talentueux
et il joue H4 Maxime ok un peu d'espace
on va menacer H5 ok ça me plaît bien
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas H4
4 minutes pour les deux joueurs Maxime
qui a rattrapé Prague dans cette finale
et qui va devoir sauver sa peau
ici avec ce pur de moins alors la
défense semble tout à fait
réalisable mais quand même des petites
questions bon certainement être posées
il a 18 abdos d'accord
donc il était champion du monde rapide
il y a 2 ans quand il avait 16 ans
résultat assez incroyable
comment on fait ici avec les Noirs je
sais pas je serais tenté pour faire un
coup de fou ça je vais tenter déjà de
jouer un petit coup de H6 quand même
pour garder cette case parce que si je
fais faux 5 à 5 le fou est-ce qu'il va
je suis pas sûr mais bon
tout simplement
il faut bien que
H5 x 5 j'aime je commence à je pense que
c'est un bon deal pour les noirs de
d'échanger les feux de casse blanche
parce que comme le disait but basse et
du fossé 8 vous promet ça a été là c'est
vrai que ça
ça arrive tout ça il fait vous aussi
c'est chèque d'abord ah ok j'ai compris
alors maintenant
on a envie d'échanger les fous de casse
blanche mais pas n'importe quel prix non
plus
on a aussi envie de pas laisser un pion
passé en E en aussi
et ensuite on fait dames 8 ou d'un mecs
pour essayer de forcer les changes mais
les blancs jouaient MG4 certainement
et on va avoir du mal à forcer les
blancs de prendre un F7 attention plus
que 3 minutes pour
ergaliser je vais bientôt réaliser ma
prouesse technique en vous mettant le
grand écran et oui
vous me dites
si vous voulez le grand écran
est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un dans le dans
le
dans le chat
est-ce que Nathan est là
j'ai pas le faire
faut que j'apprenne
j'apprenne à faire pour demain
pour demain attendez voilà si je
commence à faire des des trucs en direct
oui on veut non oui non oui
oui
non
mais moi j'aime bien le grand écran
voilà c'est ça démocratie
on va changer tout ça on va pas mettre
non
et voilà c'est la position chaque jouet
par c'est la position de la partie
fautisser chaque jouez par Maxime
envoyer 3 minutes 3 20 3 30 pour Prague
ouais vous voyez pas mais là c'est
vraiment la dernière minute qu'est-ce
qu'il va jouer il va jouer fu F7 à mon
avis alors si vous voulez je pouvais
mettre les chéquier en plus grand voilà
pour ceux qui voient mal comme moi
regardez-moi ça
est-ce que vous êtes prêt
non mais me remerciez pas
c'est pas c'est pas la peine
je sais faire c'est très sympa pour moi
donc faut aussi si il a joué
d'un F3 d'un 8 G4 et H5 et oui contre
jeu mvl
je remets à jour et voilà 5
et mvl qui voulait pousser ici mais
attention il peut se créer des
faiblesses attention ce roi peut être
pris à partir aussi en danger
maximachère avec 3 minutes contre 2 15
pour son homologue on voit plus très
bien
on voit bien quand même on voit bien on
voit bien mais la réalisation et en fait
on fait
on fait ce qu'on peut
là c'est pas mal ça me semble être pas
mal
c'est qu'on voit bien chez qui attention
à ce roi
voilà c'est chaud quand même pour Maxime
là qui est en difficulté alors la jauge
elle est pas inquiète mais nous on est
très inquiet en tout cas je le suis pas
trop juste faire G5 je crois pour fermer
tout ça
parce que on peut pas se permettre un
truc comme ça
attention je crois qu'on peut pas se
permettre en tout cas après on peut
laisser aussi peut-être
on peut laisser comme ça en tout cas il
a plus que deux minutes Maxime grave
moins de 2 minutes on est passé sous la
barre des deux minutes pour mvl face à
de 15 attention parce qu'elles sont
dures je sais position et si peu de
temps
j'ai 5 ré des réseaux chez les Noirs
ouais j'ai 5 palettes le coup très
naturel
alors Maxime essaie de voir s'il a pas
mieux que j'ai 5
j'ai 5 on peut pas quitter avec la dame
par exemple dame B5 pour revenir par là
on serait matin de coup
ça serait la contre-attaque la plus
rapide de l'histoire mais tellement
efficace
allez Maxime
Maxime
une 30 on n'est pas habitué à voir avec
aussi peu de temps
fou F2
non
non c'est pas du tout
et j'ai 5 jouets
Prague de si attendre aussi est-ce que
j'ai 5 il fait Road 7 très rapidement
et faux F2 maintenant
aucune idée voilà cette idée était
clairement de libérer la dame comme ça
sur le temps de mater très certainement
protège tout et sur Dame des 8 je
suppose qu'on va revenir on est
évidemment ok avec la nul avec les
Blancs quoique on sait jamais il peut
tout se passer dans cette hypnotes quoi
que normalement il l'a montré il l'a
montré par le passé Prague il a une aire
solide il est bon avec si peu de temps
il prend ses chances
une vanne neuf au maxi machin grave
contre une 35 pour Prague mais je vous
rappelle cette incrément de 10 secondes
par coup donc effectivement
ça reste quand même pas mal de temps
pour les deux joueurs
et je vois pas exactement comment
améliorer la situation ici avec les
noirs
je m'attends à la nulle pour être
honnête
les blancs sont trop actifs j'ai
l'impression
après pour les Noirs c'est pas très
compliqué on peut rester comme ça la
mecs
comme ça
prendre ses chances et le concept ouais
c'est ça
c'est dans le Times comme on dit donc
dans le
dans le manque de temps mutuel
cette phase qui rapporte beaucoup de
points ou en fait perdre énormément et
bien
il faut avoir les nerfs solides bien
gérer son temps est-ce qu'on peut tenter
d'amaker nous dit Mathieu Rodriguez
mesdames fuites j'ai l'impression que ah
non je suis mat
ah bon
comment je suis comme ça
et c'est le coup de c'est la
contre-attaque intéressant damaka jouer
par Prague jamais fuite est interdit
dans la fuite serait maté parfois 4
attention énorme menaces faut 4 quoi
qu'il y a encore X5 mais c'est parce
qu'on veut il joue five 5 tout de suite
bon il me fait mentir
comme ça ce qu'il est en train de dire
c'est surtout prendre un me prend je te
fais un perpète par là
ok intéressant il faut F5 il a pris et
Prague il dit tu me l'offres J6 et j'ai
fougé cette ensuite
jouer et maintenant Maxime qu'est-ce qui
peut faire il peut prendre le pion
est-ce que son adversaire aura mieux que
perpète attention ce pion qui est en
prise
est-ce que son adversaire aura mieux que
perpète et la décision à prendre allez
pas facile cette position
qu'on sa plus de son
mais s'il y a du son est-ce qu'on va
raconter
ne faites pas peur comme ça attention
si elles sont si si elles sont
ouf j'ai eu peur
on va simplement encaisser par là je
crois
et les noirs sont mieux les Noirs
poussent 45 secondes pour Maxime machin
face à
simplement 56 secondes pour Prague bon
les deux
les deux en manque de temps mais Prague
est clairement du bien meilleur côté de
la nul ici
très très impressionné
impressionnant
à le montrer vous décrez Dame des deux
on est obligé de revenir ça n'irait pas
ça serait perdant Maxime il faut jouer
et il joue fou G3 ok ok faut G3 avec 30
secondes à la pendule simplement contre
j'ai pas la ref
on prend des 6 si il veut prendre ce
pion ok ça se tient parce que le pion
des après passer serait très très
dangereux
alors il joue dans BE4 Prague pourquoi
je vous donne mes 4 parce qu'il veut
protéger son pion en D6 il est malin
comme tout notre ami Prague
que va jouer Maxime va chez Lagrave
que va jouer Maxime
il va jouer un coup droit
je sais pas moi jouer c'est une gaffe
c'est une gaffe d'après la jauge on la
sentait venir parce que franchement elle
est dur à jouer cette position pourquoi
c'est une gaffe je n'en sais rien
espérons que Prague n'est pas la rêve
non plus
espérons que prendre n'est pas la rêve
non plus je sais pas ce que c'est le
coup je vais mettre je triche je triche
pour voir le coup je triche B5 B5 est
gagnant B5 est complètement gagnant pour
les noirs
parce qu'après et puis on prend
énormément aussi
et il va jouer quoi waouh j'ai 2 ouais
ouais
parce que le pion est emprise aussi en
H4
ab5 réactions
va revenir très certainement manger deux
on a un petit spoiler on a le shikiki un
tantinet d'avance sur la sur le live il
va jouer roager de Maxime machine agrafe
très très certainement ouais je crois à
jouer et là il y a B5 qui est très très
fort B5 et gagnant
B5 c'est le coup de massue on crée le
pion passé tout en protégeant nos pions
c'est gagnant
va-t-il le voir non il prend à 5 c'est
pas mal aussi il faut prendre ici c'est
gagnant quand même d'après la jauge
c'était pas le mieux non c'est plus
gagnant
c'était une gaffe de la part de Prague
dame ouh là là on va venir chatouiller
par là
ouh là là c'est chaud c'est très chaud
faut G3 on se protège comment on peut et
attention on veut simplement pousser ce
pion secret du contre-jeu dans ma
chambre seul coup légal je vois tempo
par Maxime c'est bien joué
il a évidemment adulte quand il veut
Prague dame 4 il fait fouger 3 dans le 4
menacer dame j'ai 4 échec et mat un coup
il le voit il a rebâti un petit capital
tant de 52 secondes maxime a plus que 12
secondes pour Prague qui fait des échecs
qui étaient gagnants
il revient et il propose nul
il va répéter et nul entre les deux
joueurs incroyables sauvetage
de
Maxime va chier La Grave bravo à lui on
va aller voir qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme
autre partie allez on va voir peut-être
le jeune joueur allemand gamer face à
rajabo je vous trouve la position en
suivant illico presto
ouais ouais ouais on est bien les
parties qu'est-ce qu'il nous reste comme
partie il nous reste
qui meurt
gamer gamer face à Raja bof ou il est
bien Raja bof
il est bien Raja bof qu'est-ce qu'il y a
comme autre partie intéressante
n'hésitez pas à me dire une partie
chaude
une partie chaude gamer qui sait de
sauver sa peau dans cette finale mais je
crois que avec deux cavaliers oui enfin
cavalier deux pièces contre une tour ça
va pas aller ça va pas aller ça va pas
aller on va aller
chez un autre la 3 elle est terminée et
on a peut-être changé
il a la partie ségritchouk
greachu contre Vidy ça c'est toujours
marrant de regarder
une petite tremblent mon ami mon ami
Sacha toujours toujours la petite
tremble l'autre mais alors vous croyez
qu'il est au bout de sa vie et tout ça
mais après c'est surprenant avec Sacha
parce qu'il a toujours une seconde il
est à tremblotte
mais il vous joue un bon coup ça c'est
lui ça
c'est toujours lui
alors
c'est vrai qu'il est bon est-ce qu'il va
sauver est-ce qu'on va retour cavalier
qu'on tourne certainement ou pas j'ai
l'impression que les autres parties je
vais regarder ça sur mon téléphone tout
de suite
est-ce que les parties sont terminées
ou pas qu'est-ce qui reste comme partie
vous cachez complètement gagnant contre
la krishnaharjabo aussi et on a cette
partie gretchouk vilite qui peut durer
pendant des heures qui joue la gagne et
pourquoi
bon dans ce genre de cas c'est plutôt
les noirs qui jouaient à gagne mais bon
il y a très très peu de chance parce que
déjà faut gratter les deux pions et en
plus faut gagner pour qu'avec un tour
donc en général ça va se terminer ils
vont se quitter bons amis à mon avis
est-ce qu'il nous reste une autre partie
peut-être intéressante goket là emporter
face à Christina son compatriote tandis
que Raja BOV va en faire de même face à
gamer très probablement non mais là ça
n'a plus aucun intérêt ça va faire nul
c'est c'est complètement sûr
c'est complètement sûr que ça va faire
nul on va être une autre caméra
[Musique]
non là c'est fini on voit la victoire de
Google
la victoire et on voit gamer face à Raja
boss je vais vous mettre ça parce que
c'est plus intéressant quand même
et
là c'est juste ça n'a aucun intérêt ce
truc à moins que il joue pendant des
heures donc avec on tourne mais bon ça
se défend assez facilement pour être
honnête on va voir est-ce que gamer où
il a raté non il a pas intérêt
évidemment qu'il n'a pas raté il a deux
pièces voyez un il a fu cavalier que les
pions contre le tour donc ça va pas
mais c'est ton jamais avec peu de temps
c'est ton jamais quoique j'ai
l'impression qu'on sait là gamer qui
avait donné qui est donné du fil à
retordre incroyable à manuscarsen en
Coupe du monde
alors pour répondre aux questions de
docteur vivas est-ce qu'il y a une
partie après oui à quelle heure a priori
c'est un gros c'est un quart d'heure
après que la dernière partie soit
terminée donc on a eu 11h30 13h on aura
14h30
pour la prochaine 14h30 une partie
est-ce qu'il y a un enjeu particulier à
part les points lourds l'argent et le
prestige surtout évidemment parce que
c'est prestigieux comme tournoi non pas
particulièrement quoi que quoi ça fait
partie d'un circuit fidèle
le circuits et à la fin le le premier du
circuit filet et bien il qualifié pour
les candidats à noter que c'est Google
je crois qui est en tête maintenant donc
pour Google ça joue pas pour du beurre
après les autres je crois sont trop loin
ça se jouait entre Google et guéri
notamment qui avait gagné le tournoi de
weikandais
presque remettre mes jingle ouais
effectivement
mais bon on va pas tout compliquer full
G4 ok il va empêcher H5 pas de contre
jeu et surtout rage 7 il veut protéger
ici on voulait pousser H5 et échanger le
maximum de pions avec les Blancs
mais guérilla non et non non c'est un
peu l'injustice de ce circuit fidèle
c'est que ça se joue aussi les points se
marient dans les tours à fermer comme
vyckenzée qui certes prestigieux mais
les invitations se font la discrétion de
l'organisateur
donc c'est toujours compliqué
et voilà vous pouvez nous suivre sur X
n'hésitez pas à suivre ou moi-même
allez-y on rappelle il y a une partie à
14h30 avec Maxime H&M qui s'en est bien
sorti avec cette nul pour être très très
honnête
donc on est content pour lui
de nul première partie maîtriser contre
gretchup la deuxième beaucoup moins
il a été en difficulté mais il a sauvé
la lune
alors
des 7 tours
et petit à petit on va essayer de
pousser tout ce monde
mais il est remuant vous voyez notre ami
gamer
bon ils font ce qu'ils peuvent aussi
c'est pas si
tous les systèmes c'est pas si mal c'est
pas non plus et huit places qui sont
définies comme ça c'est une seule place
pourquoi pas
il monte le roi Raja BOV si c'est ça de
manière très professionnelle très
appliquée
et gamer en difficulté dans cette partie
plus qu'en difficulté juste complètement
foutu
et réattaque le pion est-ce qu'il y a
pas fort pousser un moment non il fait
un petit échec d'abord
et sur roi B2
ou là
là j'ai pas mes attends
attends
t'inquiète pas je vais me reconnecter
sur twitch pour base un petit peu là je
suis pas connecté là malheureusement
attendez blue fixe on va essayer de Ban
vas-y surtout tiens tu poses la question
en plus
faut que je me connecte sur notre ordi
on va essayer sur ça
alors
toi je suis de jouer là il va pousser
notre ami enfin notre ami il faut faire
un
protège d'abord et ensuite il va pousser
et H5 il va prendre un H5
ouais c'est vrai qu'il y a pas assez de
modo peut-être sur
sur twitch pour avoir ça
c'est pas grave en tout cas ça se
comporte bien merci à vous globalement
en plus
oui
tous les grands organismes on le sait
à l'échelle internationale bon
il y a quand même
problème c'est le
système de enfin il y a pas de bons mais
le système de détection qui est quand
même une voix par pays donc qui favorise
quand même
qui favorise certains arrangements
gamer je sais pas pour du beurre
c'est pas si évident de conclure de
conclure tout ça
et grichu qu'est-ce qui se passe il a
fait nul hein on est d'accord
ouais
on va faire un petit point résultat
classement vous inquiétez pas
on a pour l'instant cette partie quoi
c'est de essayer de convertir qui va
très probablement réussir à convertir
c'est pas encore fait
merci c'est gentil k4p
toujours des pseudos surprenants sur
twitch
le seul plan de toute façon pour les
Noirs ici ça va être de ça va être
poussé le purin à un moment ou un autre
mais alors il faut bien s'organiser
c'est pas évident je vous le dis
OK
le roi est-ce que c'est un bon deal pour
gamer c'est pas sûr parce que ça crée
qu'un micro je
donc je sais pas
on va voir
il faudrait vraiment le temps en cette
vue bon ben le temps c'est en seconde
contre 20 ou il a joué avec une seconde
je crois il a joué
c'est il joue avec lacrément franchement
donc vous inquiétez pas mais normalement
il tombe pas parce qu'ils ont 10
secondes par coup
puis de toute façon
[Musique]
est tourgé 6 vous voyez l'idée de
tourger 6 on peut pas tout avoir je suis
désolé je peux pas zoomer sur la caméra
sur kb5 et tout racisme donc il fait à 4
et maintenant il va faire Caliber 5 et à
3 et je crois qu'il a il a trouvé le bon
plan
gamer avec très peu de temps
le 4 c'est pour a 15 paroles
donc on peut avoir un fou cavalier
contre voilà il a échangé donc là c'est
il est en mode auto pilote évidemment
qui s'est maté évidemment qui connaît W
temoradjabov
donc il faut forcer les attention alors
les blancs à sacrifier
sacrifier cette tour contre le pion mais
on y arrive
on y arrive non ça a pas encore duré non
non ça abandonne ici ça se respecte trop
pour ne pas abandonner
à fou cavalier contre roi peut-être
qu'ils vont faire mentir
alors
roi C4 va certainement être joué
roi B4 ok faire une offre il veut pas
d'échec oh là là c'est vraiment
ça joue pas
ça ne rigole pas du tout
bon il va essayer de
gamer il peut rien faire il est foutu
allez faut tester l'adversaire non mais
là
je vous le dis
il joue au dernier moment mais bon peu
importe
et roi des trois maintenant on va mener
de faire cri V3 puis C2
ils le savent les deux que c'est terminé
je crois qu'il peut même pas sacrifier
la tour qu'on ne pion
une énorme gaffe à cause de tout
reprendre et roi C2 en orchestrer le
pion
donc probablement comment on fait il
faut F3 x 2
x 3 et pas mal pour moi c'est cavalier 2
j'aime bien
il va jouer qu'est-ce qu'il y a juste le
jour roi B1 je pense
où il va abandonner c'est l'heure c'est
l'heure Vincent
c'est l'heure
de va arriver menaçant C2
et là c'est l'heure de l'abandon
c'est terminé pour le jeune joue
allemand le numéro allemand
je pense qu'il y a pas le droit de
proposer nul abandon abandon de gamer
c'est pas une surprise du tout et on a
les résultats de la ronde avec Raja BOV
on vient de le voir ah bah tu es
Maxime va chez La Grave a fait nul
contre Prague plutôt un bon résultat au
vu de la partie il a quand même souffert
à d'où ça Torah fabuleux
et nul comme annoncer un truc et Vidy
du coup le classement qu'est-ce que ça
donne personne n'est détaché à 2 tout le
monde a laché un truc
Prague et Abdou la jeunesse au pouvoir à
une mission sur deux pour l'instant
ensuite on a mvl témoha jabov Alexander
expérimentent très expérimentés de ce
tournoi en quelque part visite aussi en
fait partie avec un point
gamer un point aussi à Krishna
et
airgaliser avec zéro sur deux en
souffrance enfin faire attention à pas
prendre l'eau complètement
mais voilà un début de tournoi
intéressant à suivre des belles parties
combatives on va voir qu'est-ce qu'on a
à la ronde 3
je vais vous mettre la honte 3
et la 3 on a vite contre mvl de joueurs
qui se connaissent très bien Google
ils sont à égalité voilà pour le
programme de cette rentrée qui devrait
débuter d'ici
9 minutes et oui
donc d'ici peu je vais en profiter pour
faire un petit break parce qu'il fait
chaud ici la fenêtre est j'ai mal ouvert
la fenêtre la fenêtre est pas ouverte il
fait chaud il fait chaud à Paris on se
plaint un petit peu voilà mais c'est un
plaisir de regarder évidemment ce
tournoi avec Maxime Vacher lagraphe qui
reprend le service dans quelques petites
minutes
face à visite avec des Noirs alors
pourquoi pas une petite victoire petite
victoire pour finir la journée
on prend non
à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title
tuesday.com/avent scoop tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
et je suis de retour pour cette
troisième ronde
du statistique chasingya rapide
évidemment il y aura un tour de Blitz
trois jours de rapides jours de Blitz et
voilà et c'est un beau tournoi et on est
à Maxime va chier la grave on va le
montrer
qui a un sur deux des bus solides il
s'en sort bien contre Prague contre nul
confortable donc pas de
pas rien de spécial pour l'instant admis
point des leaders tout va bien
pour Maxime il est noir contre vidyte
dans cette troisième onde qu'on va
évidemment
suivre on va se mettre
sur
sa caméra voilà on a visite on va
retrouver évidemment
sa partie aussi
et
alors sa partie aussi c'est où c'est
là on a vite face à mvl et je vais vous
la mettre sur le petit échiquier comme
d'habitude aussi
avec et ça a repris
mvl face à
donc
et cavalier F3 des 6 donc on va avoir
une
[Musique]
une nage dehors
très très probablement
avec une prépa
certainement de
visite qui est qui peut pas être surpris
par le début de Maxime là clairement et
fouger 5 waouh
j'ai 5 ça c'est quelque chose quand même
alors qu'est-ce qu'il va faire à priori
il va faire aussi c'est un Maxime ok bz7
il peut changer un petit peu va-t-il
changer est-ce qu'il va se souvenir
c'est la question c'est une surprise
vite normalement qui joue pas qui est un
joueur de 4 qui est pas un joueur de
siège ouverte
mais qu'il a fait un petit effort un
petit effort spécial mvl
pour essayer de bouger un petit peu
et attention quand on se souvient pas de
la théorie dans ces scènes âge d'or ça
peut jouer des tours
ok c'est une surprise de la part de
Maxime d'habitude il joue le coup
aussi
et joue ici clairement mais qui est BD7
il a voulu surprendre et là à trois
à trois de jouer
très surprenant
très très surprenant évidemment le coup
à trois qui est éventuellement des
contre des B5 B4 mais ça c'est de
l'archiprophylaxie donc il
décide de
voir d'abord comment Maxime veut
développer ses pièces et joue G6
alors intéressant clairement on va venir
en G7 sur dmd2 on va faire H6 d'abord
pour pas être confronté au coup faut H6
mais effectivement c'est très très dur à
jouer la nage de enfin
Santiago Santiago le Mira oui non c'est
très très dur à jouer clairement
les plus complexes où on voit il y a des
il y a des rangs qui se définissent ici
donc ça peut être très très chaud
fou c'est 4 ok on s'en fout
on peut pas on peut pas lui en vouloir
de faire ça clairement vous prenez cette
ne marche pas s'il y avait un petit coup
de MC4 derrière ça pourrait marcher avec
lui aussi mais ça a pas l'air de marcher
et maintenant il y a peut-être faire il
y a peut-être me faire mentir et je vais
petit rock qui x 2 tours
on va voir c'est 4 semaines en B5 aussi
mais bon on a joué à 3 pour ça donc ça a
une certaine logique
la dragada
en particulier parce qu'elle est elle
est extrêmement complexe
et très dur à gérer il faut être
vraiment dans les détails
alors qu'est-ce qui va décider a priori
il faut ces quatre camions une
indication qui veut faire petit rock
clairement
sinon il aurait joué Dame des deux pour
menacer faut H6 et on verra plus tard
pour ce fou parce que là ça fait quand
même gagner du temps ça crée une cible
possible de retourner chez qui et mais
bien sûr pardon
hop et voilà comme ça on a la position
du côté de Maxime excusez-moi j'oublie
j'oublie à chaque fois
je suis tellement habitué à regarder les
parties du côté blanc que j'oublie
effectivement du côté de Maxime on a
cette nage d'or vous voyez Maxime
surpris mais bon
il est quand même il est
il sait ce qu'il fait F3 voilà F3 c'est
une contre-indication au petit du coup
certainement faire une des deux
bon Maxime il a plus trop le choix là de
toute façon voilà petit rock
et sur Dame des deux il va aviser
Dame des deux va arriver c'est quasi
certain on peut la petit rock serait
ridicule ça a pas de sens un petit rock
clairement
mais du coup c'est bon pour la fenêtre
j'ai ouvert la fenêtre et vous entendez
rien en plus donc c'est bon là la
fenêtre est
elle est elle est pas grande ouverte
mais elle est bien ouverte
un petit peu mais je sais que ça
s'entend pas
donc c'est gagnant
j'ai de l'air il fait chaud
Dame des deux jouets
par voyez faire un grand rock et il faut
H6 et H4 typique du dragon c'est vrai
que on peut mettre de foin en C4 aussi
dans les dragons ça veut une B5 mais bon
après tout on va jouer à deux ça sera
pas facile de jouer B4 parce que à 5
toujours compliqué parce que le pion V5
va être en prise
donc
compliqué
tout à fait je commande celui-là
je pourrais le mettre tiens
monsieur
et life
le fond vert ça sert à quoi mais tu vois
pas la fenêtre
normalement il sert à mettre un fond
d'écran
autre
mais en fait ça ça colle bien les
couleurs cheesecom le fond vert
voilà c'est ça combien
je suis en bas de la tour Eiffel
donc et pas bon cavalier 5 bien meilleur
gagne du temps fouet 3 pas fou à deux OK
et là normalement le plan c'est pardon
c'est cette non dame vous décède pour C8
et 4 et c'est une course donc va arriver
ou alors H4 pour menacer H5 rapidement
on a le choix
je peux me mettre au milieu de visite
grâce au fond vert
je peux j'ai déjà fait en fait sur
chaise 24 je m'étais je me mettais là
vous voyez peut-être pas mal oui pas ma
soirée mais je me mettais au milieu
ouais à côté de la pendule on avait une
vue
grand écran et je faisais ça ouais ça
c'est assez facile
pas très dur à réaliser techniquement
très honnêtement
je peux m'ajouter sur la vue je le ferai
d'ailleurs
de m'ajouter où je veux
je vais vous faire en fait partie
alors grand tour C8 jouer tout est
archiologique ici sur Full 6 on a
toujours ses idées de fou prendre à me
prendre pour prendre ces trois mais
prends ces trois Damas 5 les sacrifices
très thématiques de la du dragon où on
attaque ici on va jouer ton C8
et on a du jeu contre ce roi ce roi
blanc donc on essaie d'éviter ça donc
sur ces 8 Chris et menaces et rend plus
difficile
le coup faut H6 pour les blancs
est-ce qu'il va faire H4 est-ce qu'il va
faire G4 ou est-ce qu'il va faire
warbeur voilà c'est les à mon avis les
trois coups candidats rois B1
roi B1 G4 ou H4 c'est les coûts vraiment
très thématique sur H4 on pourrait avoir
H5
et de jouer G4 d'abord empêche ce genre
de choses
ouais c'est ça donc moi ici je joue roi
bien comme ça sur Damas 5 on a des
cahiers 5 parfois qui marchent
et la fameuse la fameuse petite
combinaison qui prend le set échec
intermédiaire c'est pour ça qu'on a joué
Robert parce qu'il y a pas d'âme prend
des deux échec
donc c'est ça tout lié de jouer au roi
B1 qui me semble être un coup très utile
ici honnêtement
on se revoit il va devoir changer son
fusil d'épaule pour avoir
et là encore la question se pose h4g4
on sait pas
mais ça lui aurait fait salut de jouer
dans cette position
visite peut-être pas tout à fait à
l'aise avec ce genre de position c'est
pas mal pour nous ça
une sorte de dragon là
je maxime a plus d'expérience c'est
certain
on va voir
est quand même un coup quasi automatique
je crois
la
est-ce que tu as 25 et après tout FC 8
marche oui bah c'est c'est les plans tu
mets chèques 2008
c'est tout à fait les plans
on peut aussi jouer dans un genre de
position comme ça
et des choses comme ça et qui est de 2
pour menacer au 5 et attention ce fou
peut être surchargé ça peut être pris
simplement
ouais non Maxime il a jamais joué la
dragadador je pense pas ou alors très
peu ou alors en blitz mais quand même ce
genre de position genre sicilienne où il
est normalement assez à l'aise
je suis pas très inquiet
ouais c'est vrai que la le pion insiste
prend très bonne remarque d'un massacre
c'est vrai que par exemple
quelque chose comme ça c'est vrai
maintenant
et dans le moment on va assis avec les
noirs et c'est vrai que ça prend un
petit peu la case
bon après ça a deux avantages comme b5b4
hein qui peut arriver plus vite voilà je
n'aime pas pardon
typiquement il menace pour les pour les
Noirs c'est cavaliers prend on reprend
ici et donc c'est gagnant pour les noirs
et visite qui prend énormément de temps
ça normalement il y a une partie très
complexe à venir donc c'est quand même
un peu
un peu étrange est-ce qu'il réfléchirait
pas un coup comme F4 mais F4
et de pousser tout simplement ainsi que
je pense qu'il faut prendre pour
reprendre et 5 ça craint
ça c'est pas bon ça sans même pas
donc
il y a un fichier à tout ça mais
attention à pas investir trop de temps
parce que clairement ça peut ça peut se
compliquer derrière
et de venir
bien beaucoup de variantes à calculer et
le manque de temps peut se faire
ressentir la
investissement de temps pas anodin F4
reprend C3 ouais toujours un coup est-ce
que dame prend j'avais peur de me
prendre et sur quel prend le cas d'un
mur attaque le cavalier attaque le
cavalier pas l'impression que ça aille
très fort
comme ça sur cahier projet 5 on joue
puis on prend le 5 et attention
attention aux cavaliers qui est
pas terrible
donc F4 à un coup aussi qui doit
regarder
troisième coup candidat j'ai 4 H 4
quatrième coup quand
il va jouer quelque chose d'autre Maxime
qui s'ennuie Maxime qui ne se laisse pas
c'est bien
non mais vite il aime bien prendre son
temps
attention ça pourrait jouer un tour
Maxime qui s'ennuie pour parler poliment
je sais pas c'est 50 ça commence à faire
un investissement de temps assez
conséquent
pour visite ouais trop long les rapides
pour Maxime ouais bah ça en trois plus
deux ans du spectacle alors je vous
raconte pas ça va être beau
ça va être très beau
F4R de force
d'ailleurs ça marche pas
tu reprends
effectivement ouais ça ressemble pas une
bonne nouvelle ça
voilà
la main Maxime la main la main devant la
bouche qui est ici
pas énorme je crois
mais ouais trois heures et demie un truc
comme ça
toujours un peu désagréable pourquoi pas
que c'est si après ça affaiblissement on
a déjà une menace qui est prend le 4
fuites qui prend des 4
surprend attention on attaque ici
il joue quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué il a joué H4 tout
ça pour ça
H4 le coup qu'on attendait
et
enfin le coup qu'on attendait pas parce
que c'est on s'attendait à roi bien
plutôt
je m'attendais à
donc
maintenant ça donne des H4 c'est quand
même l'inconvénient
sans qu'il
s j'aime pas
j'aime pas qu'est-ce que je vous dise
moi
est-ce que je peux faire non non je vais
dire ça on n'aime pas donner le fou
peut-être ça
j'aime bien pour simplement alors j'ai
pas les chèques intermédiaire mais là on
est embêté parce que on peut pas bouger
ce fou parce qu'elle pue en 7
donc votre obligé de faire un truc pas
très agréable comme moi j'ai 7 que chose
comme ça
mais ça va pas
donc H4 peut-être sur dame à 5 la simple
invitation c'est fou point F6 aussi
surprenant que ça puisse paraître donc
pas de temps à perdre alors peut-être à
5 peut-être j'ai 4 maintenant
ça c'était thématique ce genre de truc
attention alors là je n'aime pas
regarder elle aime pas elle aime pas
elle aime pas elle aime pas elle aime
pas elle change elle change d'avis
donc faut se méfier
faut se méfier de tout ça
quoi suite prophylaxie
roi à chute tu m'étonnes qu'on ait perdu
les les trucs de les batailles de
communauté sur xoslo roi suite quand tu
veux penser à un truc pareil
hk3 je suis tu veux nous faire sur xoslo
il nous a fait perdre toutes les
batailles de communauté à l'époque
voilà je suis tu te mets dans la
dernière tour
il joue à 5 et il est venu là pour ça
ouais je suis oh là là vaut mieux passer
que j'aurai ensuite
tu m'étonnes qu'on permet
alors
joué par Maxime d'habitude dans le
dragon le fouet en E3 et donc on est
obligé d'échanger parce que sinon on
perd le foot de case noire là on n'est
pas complètement obligé même ça paraît
quand même comme quelque chose de
désirable
du coup comment on peut faire ici Dame
des trois ok il veut pas il veut pas
donner son fou
et alors s'il revient qu'est-ce qui se
passe une proposition de nul là ou quoi
ah non
y a marre des nul il faut gagner une
partie là
5 qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant parce
que on va se prendre le
[Musique]
c'est tout prend ces trois Damas 5 comme
dirait comme l'a dit à l'époque
c'est pas une question de calcul ce
genre de sacrifice c'est une question de
culture échiquier
ça tient toujours Damas 5 on a une
qualité on donne la qualité mais le roi
est faible les pions là la tour ce qui
est bien c'est quand même notre tour qui
va pouvoir aider
position est quand même il y a pas de
colonne ouverte donc c'est largement
assez de compensation c'est certain
alors Dame des trois jouets B5 ok pour
refuser la nul vraiment moi je tâterai
un coup quand même pour voir
toujours dans la demi-mesure Gary où il
a donné une mesure c'est pas son truc
alors cavalier 5 est-ce qu'il peut
vraiment changer d'un E3 c'est bizarre
d'un autre
étrange pour moi et surtout je vois pas
ce que les Blancs quoi que il y a le
vis-à-vis maintenant est-ce qu'on a
gagné quelque chose par rapport à cette
ligne oui parce que ah c'est protégé on
peut faire foi
ok avec la dame en D2 il y aurait eu
qu'elle prend le 4 et tout reprend des
quatre ok ça se tient
même les trois B5 joué par mvl alors
est-ce qu'il veut pas faire nul est-ce
qu'il a considéré que dame 3 était une
amélioration pour les blanches je pense
que c'est plutôt dame 3 qui
l'amélioration pour les blancs
on en est au niveau des résultats sur
deux pour Maxime Vacher la grave
on les a pas qui non
peut-être que alerte attendez
peut-être un truc en fait
excusez-moi j'essaie de voir
non mais sur le stream anglais ils ont
pas les alertes non plus donc je sais
pas
alors
qu'a-t-il joué B5 il a fait G4
et ne plus rigoler
c'est une course
H5 tout de suite c'était plus fort nous
dit une basse on le croit
c'est possible
de la part de Vidy dans ce genre de
position c'est qu'on va faire foi 6
donc il fait il fait ça de manière très
scolaire G4 H5 il va prendre G6 et c'est
vrai que c'est aussi dangereux
que font les Noirs ici d'un A5 peut-être
pour menacer des choses comme ça et il
prend à 3 ou pardon
c'est trop derrière mais la chose n'aime
pas du tout
si j'ai l'impression même ça c'est un
peu lent ça il y a ça
position là il y a un coup
il y a un coup pour les noirs que je ne
vois pas
c'est ça
puis on prend la main
voilà ça ça fait très mal faut prendre
ces quatre saisons français 3 et c'est
terminé donc attention Damas 5 avec la
menace B4
ouais elles sont durs ces positions
clairement
la jauge n'aime pas du tout peut-être
juste fou prends ces quatre
parce que B4 a une vraie menace je sais
pas je triche fin de journée
ah c'est fou prends avec les dessins ok
ça a du sens une idée que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure
ouais
elle est bien là
et H6 pour repousser non ça repousse pas
vraiment ça affaibli tu as faibli il a
joué 6
alors là je suis sous le choc HS
normalement on touche pas au pion du
rock
quand on se fait agresser comme ça mais
bon ça permet de sur des H5 on peut
faire G5
d'accord et c'est marrant parce qu'il
s'y attendait qu'elle prend le 3 dans 5
ok ok ok ok ok
ces échecs de 2020
donc normalement
attention
on va retourner le liveboard aussi ouais
ok d'accord
c'est vrai que sinon c'est gênant voilà
c'est fait
le live board
merci pour tous vos
premiers jours donc il faut se mettre
il faut se mettre au goût du jour
toujours un peu la panique voilà ça
allait aujourd'hui franchement
niveau technique c'était assez
tranquille
c'est une jauge indienne
est-ce que j'ai 5 qui veut faire il va
falloir intermédiaire
pour le public mais bon
les finales sont quand même pas c'est
pas la même quand on sacrifie la qualité
dans la finale
merci Emmanuel
merci de people
donc
j'ai cinq quand même très tentant
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire Maxime sur G5
[Musique]
j'ai 5 cavaliers à 5 et des 5 c'est
grave
je t'avouerai que si j'avais les Noirs
dans cette position je pensais que c'est
très grave après
toujours pareil
toujours pas et
cavalier un H5 le cavalier mvl un petit
peu ouais je crois que c'est grave
je crois que j'ai 5 et pas une bonne
nouvelle
si ça arrive et franchement je crois que
ça va arriver parce que c'est facile de
voir que sur G5 tours C3 dame français 3
on va pas être moins bien voilà il y
aura du il y aura du jeu pour la qualité
mais on sent que au moins on peut plus
faire mater il y a plus les dames
surgier donc on a une qualité nette de
plus quand même c'est dur à croire que
les Noirs même et assez de compensation
donc G5 cavalier H5 peut-être alors puis
on prend
puis on prend ça on va ouvrir on se met
on se met dans des tours prend H5 enfin
bon
coup mais même ça ça va être quand même
c'est quand même des cinq d'abord
certaines
8 et maintenant tu reprends H5 puis on
prend un truc comme ça
elle a l'air quand même sacrément bonne
celle-là puis on prend cette arrivée
attention on peut pas prendre parce que
il y a le il y a le il y a le fou qui
attaque le orange G8 donc ça n'irait pas
même éventuellement kf5 ça fait très
très peur quand même vous voyez bon là
je sais pas convaincu au départ mais
elle change d'avis donc là ça se joue
tout seul donc j'ai 5 va être très
certainement jouer qui voyage 5 puis on
prend un site finalement ok c'est un
coup c'est clairement un coup
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué vite il a joué
qui est de
[Musique]
moi niveau
peur
c'est vraiment pour empêcher de te
reprendre ces trois alors ok mais bon
ça menaçait pas
les blancs gardent quand même un bel
avantage
après je sais pas étonnant ce que je
peux faire B4 ici
apparemment pas
demain il y a quoi est-ce que je perds
la dame
ou pardon là je parle
est-ce qu'on perd la dame
c'est le bon coup là
ça va pas et puis on prend un homme
prend et là j'ai 5
et bouge
on va se prendre et ça ne va pas du tout
c'est un désastre
qui aime bien qu'il y a deux mais elle
préférait G5 en tout cas la mienne
pas vraiment
qui est de 2 et G5 les deux coups
les deux premières lignes a priori bon
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas des deux
coups qui perdent pas l'avantage
et Ben et maintenant c'est très dur pour
Maxime apparemment
peut-être ce coup de B5 qui était
maltaimé avec H6
qu'est-ce qui peut faire ici Maxime et
bien
c'est du courage quand même parce que
j'ai 5 est tellement fort
c'est tellement une grosse menace
que c'est dur à gérer je trouve pour les
c'est très très dur j'irai pour les
noirs
dernier onde de la journée ou à gare on
se retrouve demain dès 11h15 20 pour la
première onde qui aura lieu à 11h30 la
première la quatrième ronde du rapide
qui aura lieu à 11h30 pardon
dès demain et tous les jours de la
semaine jusqu'à samedi inclus
on se reposera et ce soir n'oubliez pas
à 20h vous avez soit rognan
c'est toujours sur la même chaîne que
vous suivez maintenant commenté par
stouf
est-ce que vous prendrez 4 et une idée
oui toujours
et ça me semble un peu léger ça fait que
depuis
en plus on va pas endommager la
structure parce que le cavalier qui aime
défend bien
c'est un peu trop léger voilà c'est une
idée mais c'est trop léger
cavalier H7 Sami ça c'est un coup qui
jouera jamais de sa vie Maxime c'est
beaucoup trop passif
vous allez voir il va jouer cavalier non
c'est pas possible pas jouer
et ça non trop passif mais bon
effectivement je comprends ton ton souci
moi je sais pas ce qu'il faut faire moi
je suis très embêté avec les noms j'ai
aucune idée de ce que je jouerais
pour être très honnête
allez-y qu'est-ce que vous jouerez ce
soir
ce soir
maintenant
moi je suis
comme ouh là
il a joué B4 m puis on prend mes quatre
dames ça perd la dame il a raté tout un
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe
roi des deux dame prend B2 et surtout un
les carottes sont cuites
c'est du + 3,30 là
et ça
c'est pas si simple quand même
oui
on a beaucoup de jeux là et beaucoup de
pions surtout pour la qualité
donc
c'est pas si simple c'est pas si simple
c'est pas si simple
c'est quoi le coup là pour les blancs
c'est ça
non
je sais pas
même maxime a dû voir ça il a dû se dire
c'était pas mal pour lui qui a eu deux
peut-être tout simplement
il y a plus fort
c'est Camille s'il y a plusieurs coups
pour les blancs ça veut dire que ouais
au feeling
alors c'est la partie malheureusement
roi des deux jouez dame
pardon
et toi jouer par visite menace
d'enfermer la
menace d'enfermer la dame
et du coup je crois que tu reprends ces
trois est obligé
parce que ça c'est quand même c'est pas
la moitié d'une menace tout ça donc ça
ne va pas
il joue bien les Indiens qu'est-ce que
je vous dise ils sont très forts on a vu
il y avait sur les quarts de finale je
crois qu'il y avait quatre indiens à la
Coupe du monde
bah ils sont en train de ils sont en
train de prendre de dominer clairement
ce début des années 2020 et ça parle de
terminer et salut à toi cher robinside
excellent joueur de paddle et d'échec
aussi
il court
alors là Robinson
heureusement parce que moi je cours pas
et on joue ensemble
donc voilà c'est quand même bien qui est
là qui court pas quand des deux c'est
bien que c'est bien qu'il y en a un qui
court pour deux qui est français 3 tours
C8 en menace d'un Français 3 et quel est
le 4 attention ou même cahier prend G4
donc il faut absolument bouger ce
cavalier ça c'est pas dur à comprendre
il va jouer qui avait lieu de visite
c'est quasiment certain
quoi d'autre
je vois pas
j'ai l'impression que le reste perd tout
de suite en fait
on n'aime pas qu'elle parce qu'en fait
mine de rien on s'est affaiblit et case
noire le cavalier il est important en E2
pourquoi il est important E2 parce qu'il
contrôle les cases noires
quand on fait ça le cavalier on peut pas
échanger on contrôle ces cases qui sont
quand même assez sensibles et pour
l'instant on a une on a une pardon une
qualité nette de plus avec les Blancs
et donc on a envie de simplement
d'éviter tout contre jeu d'échanger les
pièces et de gagner un final c'est ça le
plan
je vois pas quel est son option cavalier
dessin non
non c'est pas une option
là
on prend
au pire j'ai dame ces trois qui récupère
je dois retour ces trois qui est plus
forts
au moins ça ça va pas du tout
donc
je vois pas d'autres option là pour
notre ami cavalier à deux
beaucoup trop moche cavalier ado on
menace rien en plus parce que la dame a
toujours cette position de repli donc
clairement le coup je rate un truc
peut-être
alors peut-être et oui que je suis bête
et surtout on prend maintenant il y a
tombé un ou trois deux
allez on encaisse la deuxième qualité et
là c'est notre mayonnaise
E5 ferme la diagonale évidemment qui va
jouer ça le 5 jouets puis on prend
blitzer
évidemment
évidemment et maintenant on échangeait
dames et on a le plan et ça c'est une
très mauvaise nouvelle pour Maxime
qui a beaucoup moins de jeux
ouais
c'est pas folichon pour Maxime voir
complètement foutu
alors toi je fais ça ça
oblige
pour qu'il se passe quelque chose à
l'ail droit
ça c'est obligé donc je sais pas quand
je fais là est-ce qu'on me laisse
vraiment une découverte pas vraiment en
fait parce qu'elle sera jamais très
grave parce qu'on va là
est-ce que je peux prendre non
quelque chose comme ça
et c'est vrai qu'il y a tout principe
aussi qui va arriver à la tour va
arriver on a aussi c'est depuis on passe
potentiellement donc ça ne va pas pour
Maxime
Maxime là qui est dans le très très dur
est-ce qu'on peut jouer aussi tomber un
ouais il prend son temps visite il a
raison c'est écoute très important
est-ce qu'il va jouer de tour à deux
autour B1
et non encore un autre coup waouh
il veut vraiment tout lui encaisser hein
c'est genre un mode sur ça il veut lui
faire ça d'abord attaque 7 et ensuite
tourner
oui il veut pas donner aussi j'ai 4 dans
les finales voilà si ça marche c'est
hyper malin
ouais là il a très mal calculé Maxime
clairement
il faut un tour de magie pour Maxime bon
il a fait d'autres des tours de magie
mais là effectivement ça semble
compliqué visite à l'air précis
ça va pas être simple
voir très compliqué on voit on voit la
différence là maintenant il a raison
visite
c'est bien vu son truc hein
on reprend 4 vous voyez quand on prend
F3 la grosse différence c'est un peu
juger 5 c'est que voilà il y a pas
cavalier 4 ce pion là est pas perdu et
surtout celui-là il va être perdu
en clignant des yeux Tour Eiffel arrive
on va prendre ici
et c'est fini
ah bah oui mais c'est marrant je me fais
engueuler moi maintenant pourquoi je
trouve des bons coups que pour visite
bah c'est la position est pas mal
faut dire que ça aide quand même
ça aide
je peux rien ce que je vous dis moi
alors
il est dans le dur
je vois vraiment rien d'autre là un
petit coup de 4
puis on prend fou prends oui bon bah moi
on a tout ouvert c'est vrai que ça
c'était drôle un coup pas de
ouais si c'est un peu étrange il y a
sous-estimer
clairement il s'est dit je prends le
foot case noire et tout va bien et en
fait il a sous-estimé peut-être ces
idées que j'ai 5 clairement
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ici et
bien
je sais même pas ce qui va jouer Maxime
pour être honnête
la jauge mon avantage montrer davantage
de plus 3
et oui Vidy bourreau des Français
effectivement vite qu'il y avait battu
Etienne Macron à la Coupe du monde dans
ce match archi tendu il était allé loin
d'ailleurs il avait perdu contre Amazon
finalement qui a sorti tous les
meilleurs joueurs du tournoi incroyable
cette Amazon
mais ouais il avait fait une grosse
Coupe du monde je crois il avait perdu
en quart de finale simplement
en quart de finale donc il était pas
loin il était à match des candidats donc
c'est quand même c'est rageant
quand on se passe très très bon joueur
alors des D31 il nous dit que j'ai 4 je
prends
tu joues ça
je prends
le problème c'est qu'il y a rien qui se
passe quoi et ça manque d'une tour
honnêtement on est autour de moi elle me
manque quoi
Amazon vous prive des candidats ça c'est
incroyable j'étais à deux doigts des
candidats
mais là c'est trop tard
c'est aussi le problème de c'est alors
le point fort de jouer aussi vite c'est
que ça met une grosse pression au temps
mais le point faible c'est que quand on
perd des parties comme ça bon assumant
qui perdent je vois vraiment pas comment
ça peut tourner cette partie
et là c'est ça
il joue 4
il jouait 4 Maxime va chez Lagrave ça
c'est le coup
c'est le desperados
puis on prend on va être joué quasi
certainement
ce que dame
on va l'empêcher on va prendre il va
reprendre et on va prendre gentiment
même sur foodé 4 attaquent sur
attention attention les yeux parce que
là il y a à peine un échec ici je joue
je pars je pars facile
ment puis on prend F6 jouer par mvl
on va aller voir organisez-vous sur les
parties intéressante à regarder on ira
voir la fin de cette ronde évidemment
quand Maxime aura très très probablement
abandonné
je suis tenté par des choses
qui ne sont pas recommandées
il va faire fouger 7 Maxime
il y a pas de gêné
moi je crois qu'il va pas se gêner je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez
après c'est pas le seul coup
mais c'est tellement on a tellement
envie de jouer parce que
le fou
remplissant rôle un merveille d'attaque
il y a pas d'arnaque comme ça voilà
on y croit tellement pas
et puis là je reviens
ouais c'est ça j'ai le droit un petit
peu qui mais bon le roi il vibre pas ça
manque de tours de plus
ouais non ça va pas marcher ce genre de
truc après c'est peut-être ce qui va
tenter qu'est-ce qu'il a joué ça manque
de matos exactement on a un problème
c'est fou j'essaie de jouer à tempo
ouais j'ai pensé au moins sur dame prend
aussi ce serait une gaffe parce que tout
repensé de même
et surtout prends on encaisse ici bon
évidemment et c'est pas
c'est pas naïf non plus donc il va pas
jouer ça
il est pas fou
il va jouer ça ou ça
l'avantage d'attaquer
ok ça c'est bon pour nous ça
pourquoi à cause de ça 2
et 5
oh oh
OK
ok donc faut empêcher absolument ce Dame
des quatre échecs donc faut jouer dans
mes trois bah il l'a vu il jouait 3 on
est pas croyant
on contrôle bien cette case des cartes
qui pourrait faire des échecs
malencontreux
pour visite en tout cas
et dame 3 menace simplement de dire oust
à la dame
et ça n'irait pas du tout
ça n'irait pas du tout ça ne va pas du
tout on a une tour de moi tout
simplement
est-ce qu'on peut faire ça
le problème je crois que la vraie menace
c'est ça
fait mal
propose un échange attaque le
ça a l'air complètement terminé
et je fous B5 Maxime
ok il prend les cases
dans la case de sortie éventuellement ok
c'est pourquoi pas
après là j'ai même ça un petit coup de
il est pas trop tard pour se tromper
donc tomber
décidément
[Musique]
alors attention quand même 3 minutes
pour visite
est-ce qu'on regarde un autre panique
le grand écran le grand écran
pour voir
on va changer la cam tout de suite
et voyez pas si tranquille
pas si tranquille avec sa position
je peux même m'ajouter si vous voulez
pour montrer mais progrès
pas
je vais être en route
je suis là
un tout petit
je peux me mettre là
le public
pas bien là regardez-moi ça je peux
appuyer sur la pendule et tout
alors
en direct
calcotta
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué Maxime fou B5 je
fais mes ânes bien dame 5 ok tous les
casseurs veulent bientôt nous Ironside
alors il se passe quoi
il se passe quoi il va faire quoi
et attention une 50 une 50 pour visite
je vous donne le temps une 59 minutes
pour Maxime machine agrave ouh là là ça
peut ça peut tourner attention roi c'est
un
courage Fillon c'est un tour là c'est
très bizarre mais bon il y en a il y en
a une en plus pardon
aigle fond vert regardez je peux mettre
le chrome
ah ouais ça peut être pas mal ça tu as
raison
après attention plus
non
je suis vraiment
ouais je suis à fond dans le public
alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qui a joué sur Roissy 1 et
réfléchis Maxime 8,25 entre une 50 faut
poser des problèmes maintenant il y a
une tour de moins ok certes oui non
c'est pas c'est pas terrible mais bon
voilà
le public on est là en Inde en direct
en direct
on dirait que dinde on est là
on suit ça on va faire long voyage comme
pour voir c'est parti
Maxime qui réfléchit qui est pas bien et
pas bien parce qu'il lui manque une tour
c'est 5 points quand même la tour il y a
même pas un pion pour la tour mais il y
a des cases noires
c'est pas mal non on découpe chez
quelqu'un chez oui dans ma cave c'est
dans ma cave qu'on découvre quelqu'un
t'inquiète
t'inquiète Billy Jack je peux fermer je
vais fermer la fenêtre il y a des
travaux je reviens je me déplace du
public vous avez pas me voir du coup
je reviens
reviens m'asseoir
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joué Maxime il
réfléchit 7 minutes pour Maxime machin
contre une 50 contre pour visite mais
franchement je suis plus optimiste qu'il
y a quelques coups parce que là
hormis cette tour comme ça je trouve
vraiment pas ça terrible
alors attention peut-être une menace
hein faut prendre F7 trois points F7 qui
est G5 échec c'est qu'on peut on peut
redonner du matériel pour échanger des
pièces
allez Maxime
fais-nous plaisir
vas-y
trouve-nous un coup là un coup de damage
2 là un truc comme ça un truc on sait
pas trop ce qui se passe mec fort sur
menace de menacer ils avaient expliqué
son concept
ah oui merci c'est pas bien il est pas
bien le Racing il a raison
et oui ils ont même du harcings
ils fournisseur
tour des 8 ah pas mal tourner 8 menaces
de menacer vas-y fais une gaffe vite une
0,9 pour visite ouh là là c'est critique
une minute il va se faire arnaquer et
visite moi je vous le dis voilà il est
revenu incroyable
ces trois jouets
il lui reste une 14 à visite contre 6 30
pour Maxime machinagrave tour des trois
et dans les et quand même c'est tentant
autour des trois
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
moi ça me ça me chatouille
jours a-t-il
des trois peut-être dame c'est 5 ans
comme ça je sais pas c'est tours sont
tellement bizarre alors après évidemment
deux coups pour ce dans deux coups c'est
terminé il faut abandonner donc faut
faire quelque chose de rapide
ouais c'est bon signe c'est bon signe on
est d'accord
une 14 550 pour Maxime Vacher La Grave
une 14 évidemment pour visite qui a pas
l'air tranquille on le voit là et il a
pas l'air c'est pas quelqu'un qui a une
tour de plus nette
qui se comporte là on voit qu'il est pas
tranquille le vide
damage 5 puis faut H6 ouais mais bon ok
j'ai 5 trop long non
je crois qu'il va faire roi B2 vite si
on a H5 d'ailleurs ça ça monte ça
donnerait son roi B2 suite
ce serait pas bon du tout donc faut
empêcher roi B2
c'est possible qu'il soit de toute façon
il est complètement foutu hein il est à
-3,7 d'après ma jauge
alors fous des trois ouais fouder 3 pas
mal attaque attaque ici attaque ici
et peut-être après un coup comme ça de
défense foussée d'eux hein quand même
être obligé de changer les pièces alors
certes il faut prendre récupère un pion
mais c'est pas ce qu'on veut on veut
pour récupérer plus cher parce qu'on est
pas bien sinon
je tourne tous les jours
mais bon d'avoir un truc sur tour des
trois c'est quoi le coup sur tour des
trois la variante on va regarder dame
c'est 5 et ouais je vous l'avais dit
c'est 5
la F4 il y a quoi et deux
ouais
non ça n'irait pas
il est relax se trouve
la
damage 2 on dirait ous non
et attention sur un échec comme ça hop
on va se cacher une fois qu'on se cache
et que les tours jouent et on a une tour
de plus dommage de jouer
ah mais d'un match de tournage de va
arriver
évidemment qui a joué toi de visite
il le sait qu'il est complètement
gagnant
et non je vous fout ces deux
ok toujours la même idée on fait passer
le roi et ensuite on va se venger par là
c'est un bon coup ça empêche tour des
trois en plus ça c'est pas mal du tout
allez on y a cru on y a cru mais je
crois que les carottes sont cuites là
quand même bien organisé
notre ami notre ami visite il a il a
très très bien joué
il était très bon en cette fin de partie
en fait il était très bon toute la
partie tout simplement
il s'est mis un peu mal au temps mais
bon si je joue des bons coups quand il
est mal au temps qu'est-ce que je vous
dise
c'est pas un problème
alors tous ces deux et je crois que
c'est c'est très très dur pour Maxime
pour revenir dans cette partie il faut
tenter un dernier piège
je le vois pas honnêtement le dernier
piège
mais bon et s'il a joué il a joué F5
ouais bon foutu pour foutu la raison
il veut jouer 5 évidemment menace dame 6
énorme menace de la part de visite
vraiment
un coup désespéré mais bon en même temps
il faut 5 peut-être ouais
quand même
fou B3 pour faire très mal
si on voit je suis petite tactique
une tactique
assez simple malheureusement pour des
joueurs de ce niveau
que j'ai 5 c'est la position de la de la
partie là je coiffe C4 ouais il va
empêcher les échecs sur la diagonale
mais bon parce que ça empêche vraiment
est-ce qu'il y a pas fou B3 là qui
pourrait faire mal
vous B3 a l'air très logique et empêche
tout 20 secondes 20 secondes pour visite
il a joué oh il s'est fait arnaquer
3 B2 tour des trois mais non
mais non
il s'est fait arnaquer c'est non
on va voir ça au ralenti après mais la
roi B de tour des trois était joué c'est
énorme quelle arnaque
il a complètement raté ça vite il joue
demain il est foutu maintenant d'après
la jauge il est passé de plus 4 à moins
4 pro le malaise oh le malaise
effectivement
oh là là le coup de bol de Maxime
machine à café très bien
plus que très bien qui est gagnant
d'après la jauge ça me semble pas
complètement évident pourquoi
mais en tout cas il est de retour dans
la partie
fais jouer simplement fou B3 qui était
complètement gagnant mais il faut un peu
de réussite c'est une faute
professionnelle de pas avoir de chance
c'est clairement la faute
professionnelle du joueur de haut niveau
il faut avoir de temps en temps ce petit
coup de réussite qui permet de se
remettre dans les parties et peut-être
de l'emporter là
alors comment ça se passe cette histoire
est-ce qu'on prend ici
on prend ici du matériel encore alors
comment on fait pousser trois dames
peut-être tourner le coup on va je vais
regarder je triche c'est tour dedans le
bon coup mais non
tour des deux et le coup gagnant
pourquoi sur Tours il y a quoi et
surtout ça je me fais aider il y a dame
D6 menace dame prend B4 ouh là là c'est
pas simple c'est pas simple je vous le
dis mais c'est de la géométrie et Maxime
il peut le voir tout ça allez Maxime
qu'est-ce qui joue
non
mais non
sur ces trois jouets il est de nouveau
foutu
aïe aïe aïe aïe
[Musique]
ah il est de nouveau non 0,5 bon c'est
pas foutu mes starshi gagne un tour des
deux
oh là là là là
oh là là
quel dommage quel dommage mais c'est pas
fini tout peut se passer dans cette
partie 2 minutes 10 pour Maxime la chair
à 30 secondes pour vite
et comment on fait maintenant comment on
fait comment on fait Maxime vient nous
le dire comment on fait peut-être d'un
proche-4 non il va carotter un pur si
peu 41 pion il va le prendre
Maxime si ça traîne il prend et il prend
et voilà je vous l'avais dit quand ça
peut prendre un pion ça veut et ça
marche pas par contre
introuvables pour faire tourner vite
c'est trop dur c'est trop dur ton j'ai
un jouet et ça redevient égal
ouais c'est deux joueurs qui sont quand
même des de très fins calculateurs qui
font beaucoup d'erreurs
dans cette phase de jeu mais je vous
l'ai dit garder du temps pour visite
c'était pas une mauvaise idée parce
qu'il a gavé au moment où il était
gagnant
et incroyable à ce qui se passe
maintenant je remets je fais un petit
coup de un petit coup d'update
non donc fous des cinq jours
par Maxime qui est mieux là et
franchement il peut la gagner cette
partie il peut la gagner parce que un
roi comme ça dans les courants de Maxime
c'est pas simple pour s'en dépatouiller
de notre ami Maxime 19 secondes pour
visite il a plutôt intérêt à se dépêcher
joue fou B3
la géométrie trouvait à tempo par Maxime
bachelagraf qui est le coup qui est le
bon coup d'après la jauge pour pourquoi
c'est le bon coup j'en sais rien moi
c'est de jouer et là pareil à damage 2
rois C3 dames 5
géométrie roi C2 dame 2 roi C3 dame trop
on gagne la pièce c'est gagnant pour
Maxime Vacher La Grave
Rocket l'arnaque
mais quelle arnaque incroyable cette fin
de partie incroyable
on va évidemment retourner chez qui
pourra du point de vue de Maxime et
c'est complètement gagnant
oh là là c'est dingue c'est dingue ce
qui s'est passé je crois des trois
visites mais voilà il perd le fou sur
place il y a deux pions maintenant deux
minutes contre 10 secondes aussi
oh là là Maxime qui nous a fait une
arnaque mais une arnaque
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on y a toujours cru non c'est pas
vrai
on y a pas toujours cru un moment on
était un peu on était un peu dans le dur
quand même je pense que Maxime aussi
était dans le dur
Maxime était dans le dur
on se met derrière Maxime allez
allez Maxime il faut encore être précis
prends son temps une 15
une quinze il a bien raison de prendre
son temps mais dans ses positions là où
c'est ça
encore les 41 pions ça c'est ça rigole
pas faut pas laisser traîner
ouais mais c'est bien que quel âge 3 ok
pour faire tourner au cavalier F4 bon il
fait ce qu'il peut visiter elle est très
dur à jouer cette position
avec très peu de temps il y a des
chèques de partout comme ça comme ça
bref ça va pas ce pion qui est faible ce
pion qui est faible et au F7 la victoire
ça c'est un coup j'ai pas la rêve du
tout mais sur OK il protège en fait ok
je sais qu'il veut faire 8
rigole pas
c'est les meilleurs celle-là j'ai pas vu
ça m'arrive pas souvent de gagner je
vais pleurer mais en tout cas c'est
c'est les meilleurs c'est les meilleurs
de gagner comme ça on est tous on est
tous un petit sourire
on est content c'est les meilleurs à
gagner celle là ça c'est sûr
c'est sûr
fou c'est qu'à tour c'est 5 allez
il fallait
gratter le pion
c'est tellement lui de faire des
problèmes moi ça
regardez regardez-le et envie de le
prendre il regarde c'est son premier
coup c'est le premier coup qui leur
visage vous le garantis et le Cook qu'il
joue c'est pris
on rigole pas tous ces six oui bon ton
C6 certes il veut prendre ici ok ok
c'est pas grave comment on fait
maintenant
j'en sais rien peut-être un petit coup
de fou des cinq sympa là pour faire des
MP3 et je t'encaisse ici
allez pire à perdre ah ouais elles font
mal ah oui ça effectivement c'est les
pires à perdre ah ouais non ça c'est
parti qui font plus mal
on se dit mais franchement quel est quel
genre de crétin j'ai été pour jouer roi
B2 jouer fou B3 alors je pensais les
deux gagner j'ai fait un petit peu
choisis un petit peu au hasard j'ai
pensé que les deux étaient très bons et
en fait non
d'ailleurs n'importe quel coup qui je
crois que tous les coups gagnent en fait
tous les coups légaux gagnent
moi j'ai 8 et ce serait vraiment stupide
ça donnerait tout reprendre ici sur
échec ce serait peut-être encore gagnant
donc là ok il protège tout mais il est
tout protégé comme ça ok ok c'est pas
mal c'est pas bête non mais rendons lui
hommage c'est pas bête vas-y non allez
allez
vas-y envoie-nous ça il fait un petit
échec d'abord ok accordez les chèques
allez pousse nous ça 40 secondes pour
Maxime machin à 28 secondes pour visite
ça y est ça joue sur un crémant et roi
des trois vas-y pousse moi spion Maxime
pousse moi ça
il a joué 5 non
pousse moi ça allez
allez on pousse
et on pousse c'est poussé
c'est poussé par mvl évidemment que
c'est poussé et oui le plan est simple
le plan est simple pas d'homologue en
face donc on pousse jusqu'au bout sans
en faisant attention au petit arnaque
petite arnaque bon là pour l'instant ça
me laisse rien ça serait quand même
tentant de continuer
et ça pousse
et ça continue
ça continue tout rose
ou Dame des 6 ça c'est pas mal comme
coup parce qu'attention menaces à
découverte
et menace la tour 1 alors là ça pue le
peu attention quand même peut-être
peut-être aussi d'abord
attention Maxime 20 secondes qui descend
en dessous des 20 secondes
de pas se faire un acqué dans l'autre
sens quand même 15 secondes E6 joué
oh là là et plus que 20 secondes pour
Maxime contre 20 pareil pour visite
trois mais alors ça ça va pas suffi mon
ami un petit échec oui ça c'est très
bien joué
on peut faire un petit vous savez la
petite les petits échecs là pour gagner
10 secondes à la pendule déjà et après
on voit se remettre une minute souffler
un peu mieux pas jouer sur les secondes
se remettre une minute à la pendule et
après on voit là il va là il va lui
coller quelques échecs vous allez voir
Maxime Maxime machin grave c'est un pro
il va évidemment coller quelques échecs
et
non
ah ben non il me fait mentir
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire avec son
F6 ok il veut protéger son pion cavalier
4 sur roi prend
gagnerait facilement
il peut prendre Maxime et après il a le
pion à qui file c'est complètement
terminé c'est plus simple certainement
on reprend le 5 va être joué
ça va être joué
ah non pas du tout pas du tout ça pas du
tout été joué il a pris un cadre tu
reprends et j'ai 5 ok c'est bien aussi
ça évidemment et à 3 à 2 il protège ses
pions ce pion là est protégé par la dame
c'est terminé
il va abandonner vite
non qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il a joué
quoi sur tour H&M Maxime alors toi a été
joué
dans le pré F3 tour H6 et roi F5 tout
reprend le système des cinq ça va forcer
l'abandon d'un mec aussi ça arrive à
suivre fini
en quelle victoire de Maxime va chez
Lagrave qui fait lui qui fait le nom de
la tête qui est dégoûté qui avait une
tour de plus effectivement on peut le
comprendre qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a
Google je vais vous mettre ça tout de
suite en partie on va voir ça Google 17
ans contre grisou 40 ans c'est beau
c'est beau les échecs pour ça aussi
intergénérationnel inclusif magnifique
et sa dernière partie et on voit cette
partie
entre gooche qui a les blancs contre
gris de chouk puis en plus pour le pour
le joueur expérimenté on va pas dire le
vétéran ritchouc la finale de tour
fière de toi elle va être mieux
à la finale de tour
mais grichu qui a quand même une
technique assez fine en finale de tour
est-ce qu'il va essayer de la gagner
est-ce qu'il va faire F5 là pour monter
le roi
parce que attention je suis un scénario
comme ça ça fait quand même nul
il va faire peut-être B4
sa chatte attention grosse technique et
voyez grimace parce que il va pas
commencer il joue B4 évidemment qui joue
B4 roi G3 joué par Google
et il va faire F6 ou roi G7
ouais il fait F6 Sacha
est pas facile à tenir celle-là parce
que sur tout reprend on reprend
attention maintenant il y a tout droit
tombé trois qui arrivent elle est pas
facile celle-là tenir contre un nocif un
technicien que Alexandre F3 tempo
qu'est-ce qu'il est là
qu'est-ce qu'il est là ça fait deux fois
qu'on le voit se défendre comme un
diable contre Abdou déjà
il est incroyable il va faire tourner
il fait dans la tête
merci restez un peu n'oubliez pas pour
ceux qui partent parce qu'ils ont fini
de voir ml n'hésitez pas demain c'est
11h30
prise d'antenne à 11h20 petit récap tout
ça
car on se réveille on se met bien
alors
bref tomber 7
et
maintenant comment fait-on
il a joué quoi Google
c'est bien joué ça et après à faire
tourner 4 F5 tour des 8
ok dès que la tour pas le problème c'est
qu'il y a ça
ça va faire nul la Tour Blanche et trop
active
ok j'oublie trois Sacha
ça pousse
je m'amuse comme je peux en bougeant
alors B3 tours C8 jouer pas à goûter ce
qui va simplement attendre maintenant je
suppose
dès que le roi va essayer de venir il va
aller là et dès que la tour elle essaie
de venir il va là
c'est aussi simple que ça
ah ouais magnifique on tourne en
situation on va regarder le classement
ce que ça donne au classement est-ce que
ça nous met Maxime en tête ou pas
bien pourquoi pas voilà ça défend bien
ça défend fort du côté de Google
évidemment comme d'hab on connait Google
ça
c'est quand même la marque des très
grands
était déjà comme ça très très dur à
battre
Carlson évidemment
les joueurs les plus grands joueurs sur
les plus dur à battre
toujours il n'abandonne jamais
alors
comment on fait maintenant
ouais
est-ce que je peux mettre l'horloge en
plus grand
c'est vrai que je pouvais mettre
l'horloge mais je pense savoir comment
en fait
je vais essayer de m'organiser sur ça
ouais d'accord
je pense que je vais y arriver assez
facilement
bon mais je pense que honnêtement
ça me paraît pas très compliqué
et comme ça on a le temps
on a le temps les deux joueurs et là on
voit à 10 secondes chacun
et
tomber 4 parce que le reste est en place
c'est pas difficile de faire des petits
ajustements comme celui que je viens de
faire en mettant dans les gradins
bon ça reste toujours complètement nul
on a échangé les déplions mais bon de
toute façon il faut bien qu'il progresse
avant ou un autre Cooke
qui a quand même
il faut qu'il fasse attention quand même
Google
là
il fait Roger 5 d'abord OK
paraît très logique on gagne de l'espace
sans se mettre dans les échecs donc tous
ces trois cookies
on va faire ça
avec les Noirs ont pas beaucoup
progressé
de 1755
mvl peut-être un rapide c'est le rapide
et ensuite on va faire
certainement
si ce
il tourne un peu il a raison il n'y a
pas de risque c'est la partie de la
journée donc on peut essayer de tout
donner et en plus il y a quand même des
chances de gain si vous cache se trompe
bon
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il va se
tromper honnêtement
c'est pas très compliqué il faut garder
le contact avec ce pion et ce pion
attention
faciles à jouer mais bon de pas oublier
à pendu remarquer quelque chose qui
tombe pas en général c'est très très
rare
toujours aussi concentré qui rigole pas
et qui tient sa finale
alors attention quand même
le roi qui s'active
et où est-ce qu'il va après ou là il a
joué qu'une seconde Google
il n'y a plus que en seconde
et ben
et
attention il donne de l'espace F4 F3
il fait chèque il va revenir
la petite grimace de Sacha ils ont
refait un petit capital temps 22
secondes pour grichu 31 maintenant 40
pour gokesh
clairement Sacha qui tourne en rond mais
il y a pas vraiment de plan en fait
c'est ça le problème
qui a eu chaud aujourd'hui on va pas se
mentir il a eu chaud dans la deuxième et
il a eu très très chaud dans la
troisième qu'il a fini même par gagner
ce qui est quand même assez pour
retournement
et donc il met et qu'il met en tête
et qui va donner beaucoup de choses à
regarder demain évidemment avec un
encore plus intensité
alors 4 il va lui coûter un petit échec
où est-ce qu'il va réclamer la nul en
fait
attention j'ai l'impression qu'après ça
peut être trois fois déjà
il va jouer au F4 est-ce qu'il va
réclamer Google
il va réclamer
ça c'est les nerfs solides attendez je
vais regarder
on va regarder ça ensemble alors il y
aura 6
si ces trois fois je suis assez
impressionné quand même
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit à tour F3
c'est la première fois
excusez-moi
ah une fois
ah non mais c'est tout rêve 300 coups
[Musique]
de la main mais c'est la première fois
il sait même pas même pas deux fois
il s'est trompé bon facile à dire
évidemment
trois fois parce que franchement ça
aurait été impressionnant bon c'était
même pas même pas une fois même pas deux
quoi
même pas deux faites parce qu'il a joué
tous ces trois là
ça va faire du temps en plus pour
pour Sacha il se passe quoi s'il a faux
je crois que c'est une minute pour gris
de chocolat attention à la deuxième
réclamation
fausse ou un coup illégal je crois que
ça perd la partie
effectivement là vous voyez il souffle
un petit peu il peut réfléchir il y a
pas de plan et tout ça
ouais ça change tout le temps c'est une
minute pour un feu un coup illégal
récemment je connais les règles
c'est 0 fois ouais c'est ça c'est une
fois
oui oui
c'est la première fois que cette
position apparaît
c'est génial comme quoi même les jeunes
ça fait plaisir
ouais je pense qu'il a pas fait exprès
en plus
il réfléchit pas comment tenir il sait
très bien il attend
alors quelle va être le temps remis à
gretchouk
c'est dommage qu'on va pas la pendule
c'est énorme ouais c'est génial il était
pas content
il a même pas arrêté la pendule ni rien
c'est quoi ces deux minutes ou une on
sait pas
ouais là j'ai perdu la pendule même même
moi j'ai perdu la pendule là je vois pas
de me rapprocher du coup dernier mais je
vois pas
je crois que c'est une minute
ok moi j'ai 5 jouer
et faire ton C3 évidemment
disons il a fait une il a fait une
réclamation là
je fais
soirée dans l'open day du championnat de
France salut amical à nos amis de l'Open
D
du championnat de France je plaisante
bien évidemment toute amitié mais voilà
j'ai joué moins expérimenté ça peut se
voir ce genre de choses
c'est quand même très étonnant qu'il
fasse une réclamation et il y a eu zéro
fois
je peux pas descendre la cam j'ai pas ma
juste au TV ah oui
j'ai pas la c'est pas là quand même
alors attends qu'est-ce qui se passe là
on va quand même revenir à nos moutons
est-ce qu'ils ont update ouais une
minute contre 47 secondes ça joue encore
ouais 6 et ranger deux jouets par Google
je voyais vraiment pas de plan je crois
93 coups déjà
une minute 16 pour goûter chez 40
secondes pour quelque chose que vous
pouvez lui donner le temps que vous
voulez
à Alexandre qui va toujours trouver
moyen de se mettre mal au temps
oui
mais effectivement
[Musique]
ouais je peux en mettre
à côté des joueurs comme ça vous aurez
une idée
ça va être ça va être faisable parce que
par exemple je peux faire ça
mais là j'ai un je pense qu'on va pas
avoir regardé je vous montre
on va faire ça en direct
je peux les je peux les agrandir les
temps en gros je plaisante
en noir comme ça
je pense je vais faire ça
va être pas mal
parce que là sinon vous voyez vous voyez
pas bien non
et nul nul signé entre Alexandre et
[Musique]
gokuche on va pas bien ouais non il faut
que je mette un plus grand ok nul et
donc maintenant on va regarder les
résultats et donc nul entre Google
mais il a battu Vidy tant mieux rajabo
ça et prend un acte a battu contre gamer
maintenant c'est à mon avis ça fait un
gros resserrement
et oui et je vous l'avais annoncé
keradjabov 2 sur 3 gamer 2 sur 3 mvl2
sur 3 Google 2 sur 3 et voilà cocorico
Maxime va chez Lagrave qui fait une très
très bonne première journée sur le plan
comptable en tout cas
et voilà qui a bien arnaqué visite quand
même ça a été une partie rebondissements
et trois joueurs à 50% après on a
gretchu abdosa torrov ennemi Philippe et
à Krishna dernier avec zéro et demi on
va regarder peut-être la première ronde
de demain
donc demain on se rejoint à partir de un
peu avant le début donc 11h30 des
parties n'hésitez pas à vous mettre un
petit rappel voilà un petit un petit
truc abonnez-vous à la chaîne évidemment
aux différents réseaux sociaux mvl aura
les blancs contre Vincent Kim
ce sera
demain du coup j'ai mis le truc en
transport c'est possible mal en
transport
demain à partir de 11h30 pour suivre les
aventures
de notre ami Maxime Vacher La Grave et
pour l'encourager
à demain merci infiniment de m'avoir
suivi n'oubliez pas ce soir 20h soir on
Yan sur jescom ciao ciao
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier du